比如说我们女生我们无所谓这吊什么吊牌。
大概对我只要穿上舒服这不就行了嘛？
但我觉得男性好像对于体验。
可能更重视他绝对的这个数值。
不行好
我是觉得小白不要上来就买出公衣。
你用不上
你又不去六千米海吧？
就就像谢老板说的。
其实可能你就买个雨衣够用了。
你是就第一次买个一次进去。
也行
哈喽大家好
这里是月下户外频道。
我是老柴
今天这期依然是大家喜闻乐见的。
装备系列
所以先预告一下
接下来的讨论当中。
我们会大量提及各种装备。
所以买买买党们可以期待。
那这些节目的比较特殊的是。
我邀请来了两个
在我认为户外装备的购买经验上。
非常非常丰富的同学。
一方面是购买
一方面由于他们俩在各自领域。
也越来越专业
非常有影响力
因此估计也收到了很多品牌的投位。
因此我先
先请两位介绍一下自己吧？
谢老板和Mia先跟大家打个招呼。
大家好 我是谢老板。
一个人爱户外的硬汉。
特别吃
软饭
这是以前的我的词。
以前的词都给
软饭指的是什么？
我确实有点怕老婆。
第一个
第二个就是那个
我其实是
就是为了跟那个硬汉压运。
软饭硬汉
对对对
我压运
另外一个确实
我在我们家反正没啥地位。
这是事实
真好
难怪谢老板提出要录一期。
跟这个女性选择装备有关的话题。
我觉得你还是非常尊重女性的。
我是怕女性
还怕恐惧
那我们也这个乐见其成。
Mia是我们老朋友了。
跟大家打个招呼
大家好 我又来了。
老差前面介绍说
各自领域予产
什么越来越有成绩。
介绍国外领吗？
大家好 我是国外领。
那我们欢迎
硬汉软饭吃
爱吃硬
爱吃软饭的硬汉谢老板。
其实谢老板的小红书的介绍是。
兼职外博主权职
是一个动画导演
动画导演
那我先问你们
第一个问题
你俩各自拥有多少件。
户外装备
大概七
大概七 是吧？
那我就数不清了
这个不是那个
这个就是吹噓
就是我确实不太知道。
我不是说多
就是我有点
我不数这个
我也不算这个
反正你每天有积累带。
然后有出去的就是这样。
但有一个房间
满满的都是装备
是 是 是
就一个房间
几千件可能有
那没有
我不知道有没有
几千件我不知道有没有。
但是肯定
就是千八百件
应该是什么问题
就都算上什么的
谢老板在各个平台。
其实粉丝量多很大。
大家如果去搜
谢老板的户外Vlog。
每一个平台都是这个名字。
都是这个
都可以看到他
然后你大概浏览一下。
谢老板的主页
就知道光他
经手评测过的装备。
那现在大概
你印象中
大概等有几百件
肯定有
对 差不多
也数不过来了
你做了我大概有五年了。
五年了
你想想
一年我差不多有
七 八十支视频
八十支最少吧？
就是这种的
五年了
那光视频
每个礼拜就算一个。
对吧 那也很多
都几百件
对对对
而且谢老板
特别擅长做横向评测。
所以你一支视频里面。
可能同时就要出三五件。
至少的
对
所以我觉得
上千件肯定是有
Mia你有多少件户外装备。
我没数过
但我觉得
应该有个两百件
但我是衣服比较多。
因为我不怎么？
一不精致录影
二不太玩重装
所以我有很多就是可能。
那个
重装的时候要用到的什么？
炉子呀？
对
吹据这些我是完全没有。
我就主要是衣服多。
有一天我去Mia家。
跟她联合办公
然后她在跟我讲的。
一个产品的时候说。
哎 我给你看看这个。
然后她说着说着
就拿出了七八九件。
光是
我们那天聊的是苏干衣。
光苏干衣你就拿了好多件。
出来 对
那是因为
以前有运动
苏干衣使用场景比较多。
健身的时候也能穿。
你看这就是男女的区别。
女孩呢把所有的钱。
都花在的衣服上
然后呢男孩把所有的钱。
都花在了装备上
因为我觉得有时候装备吧？
像什么呢像是那种。
像玩具
就比如说批评凑凑。
拿着深圳摸摸
甚至有些那种
刀斧具什么的
很多人不理解
我就会那种拿着摸。
然后看
爱不试手
就认识深圳有的时候。
有这种人物
比如说我有的以前会有一个。
特别喜欢的东西
我会把它放在我窗头。
半夜拿起来拍
那都不至于啊？
但是就说会放在窗头。
那是得怕老婆
老婆一睁眼说
她就玩刀呢？
特别喜欢
对我们来说就相当于。
就像男孩没长大
虽然我四十来岁了。
但是男孩没长大
就喜欢那种玩具
我就这个
把玩
女孩有这种吗？
没有吧？
咪娅想了想
我只会把玩各种包。
我之前有过想买刀。
但是就是也是
跟我们领队聊了一下。
就某一款特别好
我都忘了牌子了
我说OK好
我想说我就回头买一把。
就可能就够了
我不会
可能像谢老板这种。
买好多
很像评测
然后把玩
你敢不敢把玩
那你以前对包的迷恋。
是跟这种类似吗？
你说是明牌包
还是户外包
这是两个设施的
也一样
也没有
我还是爱买衣服
就我一直都是喜欢买衣服。
明白
包也没有很迷恋
也就是女孩
愿意投资自己
男的呢？
愿意投资自己的爱好。
是吧？
也不能完全这么说。
但是刚好谢老板提到了。
我们今天的主题
就是
户外产品怎么选
男女买装备
到底有什么不同
我本来当时还选了个。
被选标题叫
买了这么多年的户外装备。
我们发现男女最大的区别。
所以我们聊着聊着。
就发现已经有这个分歧了。
我们
首先我也想问问谢老板。
其实今天我特别开心。
是谢老板那天跟我说。
我们那个聊一期
男生跟女生
选装备有什么区别。
你为什么突然心血来潮。
有这么一个想法呢？
因为我跟谢老板
认识已经有两三年了。
其实最早我很早的时候。
就邀请过谢老板说。
来上节目吧？
谢老板一直这个迟迟卫动。
突然有一天说
我想聊这个话题
是吧？
我是这样
因为我知道你做不各做得。
很好
但是我觉得又没有什么？
特别合适的选
因为你偏女性多一点。
我一个老爷们
如果过来聊女性的东西。
感觉有点奇怪
而且插不进去
但是有一天
那有一个姐妹
她邀请我参加一个活动。
然后里边就涉及到那些。
女性相关的这种装备。
然后我就旅着旅
我说那我带10个。
我带10个女孩的。
我认为女孩会喜欢的装备。
我说你这样
你给我打份
你觉得这个打几分。
再打几分
我还没去呢？
但是我要准备这10件装备。
我准备的时候我发现。
我说这个话题挺好。
消费力非常强大的。
这些女性他们的户外装备。
其实可选的并不是很多。
我认为
那有些流通版
那都是无所谓的
但就说针对女性的。
这种产品就不多很多。
所以我说那
找老柴聊聊
我说有没有可能再聊一起。
那不同视角
我说我男的
包括我有些误区
你们也帮我纠正纠正。
就这个意思
太好了
我们三个今天
刚好代表了三种角色。
谢老板更多的是
男性户外装备爱好者。
并且做了大量的评测。
对于技术和功能
包括我们刚刚
节目开始之前
他一看Mia身上的一件衣服。
给我克服了很多
对 就是很多细节。
谢老板制作
非常地要了解
那Mia是我们一个。
免刑的女性户外
装备的消费者
是一个超级买卖的大人。
差身文具多
并且Mia这两年。
深度入坑户外
图布了很多地方
然后也开了
自己户外的新的频道。
你可以跟大家介绍一下吗？
我没开吧？
我开了吗？
我没开
你开了呀？
想不想做了一个新的号。
但才发两篇笔记
别给大家说
那我们这样
我们可以等一等
你可以先说
我们过去嘲笑你去。
好不好
行
你先说
对
叫Mia在野
就是野外的野
对 在野才发了
两三篇东西吧？
因为Mia一直是。
我们月下坏频道
最受欢迎的嘉宾之一。
我听说了
因为大家喜欢
买买买的
对 它已经带动了。
非常大的消费了
对 我讲不了别的。
我只能讲我买了啥。
对 然后我代表的视角。
我其实没有消费特别多。
但我主要是
品牌开发的角度
和行业观察的角度。
多一点
所以我们三个聊聊。
这一期我觉得也挺有趣的。
然后我再跟
谢老板聊这期准备的时候。
他说
咱们别老是那个聊。
什么成长 自由
什么的
说现在就是女性
谈到这个女性的
户外运动
大家好像都是高举。
这种精神奇致
你的观感是什么样的。
我觉得其实这个挺好。
但是呢？
它有点让我觉得
它是给我感觉
它在擦一个流量的边。
它如果说
真的是你要觉得
这个事好
你说你真想这么聊。
但有的时候呢？
大家会觉得
我是个内容出身的。
比如说我觉得
这个是不是
它话题比较强
容易有共鸣
所以大家爱聊
这是我的一个感觉。
它一旦有这样的一个需求。
它这量就会变得很大。
那聊的内容
就会比较单一
难道聊女性
就一定要聊
所谓自由
或者是说这种
这些东西吗？
难道不能聊点别的吗？
不能聊点需求吗？
就是不用那么高举高打。
我觉得可能更
是不是也挺好玩
我说那天他说那个。
米娅说那个
防晒的那个高
我当时就中草了
我说搜了半天
没搜着
那国内没有卖的
是吧？
对 就是
这个产品
一般是冲浪的人
会喜欢用
但其实对于户外场景。
我觉得有些女生
你出去徒步的时候。
你想补防晒的时候。
你的手脏了吧？
你咱往脸上糊
这东西特别适用
但是就国内
很少有品牌在做
我当时就觉得
我说那这么多
跟女性相关可以聊的。
就我就
因为我知道
你肯定不会
你说没事不用担心。
这个我们不会聊这个。
我就怕
我说千万别高举高打。
这事聊完之后
会显得没有那么有意思。
明白了
米娅的观感
因为今年三八的时候。
我们共同的好朋友。
超哥还发了一条微博。
他就说
哎呀？
这个妇女节的营销。
怎么越做越让人觉得。
有点没劲了
就是
大家可能都只是举旗帜。
你对这事的观感呢？
因为我做市场景
其实你刚刚提到
这个时候
我还想想说有吗？
有什么关于女性相关的。
这个户外品牌
或者说女性类的产品。
或者说像你说的
妇女节种节点
大家在讲这个解放。
在讲这个自由吗？
我还想了一想
但是随着
介老板刚才说起来。
我脑海当中
脑海当中
好像确实浮现出来一些。
以前看到的一些
这个marketing上的。
Camping
我自己对这件事情的看法。
就是
嗨 你就动不动
要给我讲生活方式。
你就不就是
你不就是想
把产品卖贵一点
就是跟我整整这个。
你就是要上产品牌溢价嘛？
所以你才给我讲
故事
你给我营造生活方式。
因为你纯讲
比方说缝制工艺
原料什么的
需要费者感受不到。
这里边的
怎么说
让我产生想往的那些部分。
但是你一旦跟我说。
这东西对吧？
向上制媒
对吧？
靠这个来打动
引设一些品牌
这种
这么具体的
老差立刻
刚才唱了一下时候。
没关系
我们就是主打一个真实。
我的感受是
因为刚好前段时间。
参加了一个论坛
叫link大会
然后我当时跟他说。
我觉得女性的需求。
可能跟男性的
会不太一样
是他会更立体
比如说我们会有
功能上的需求
有
审美上的需求
也有精神上的需求。
但我觉得三个需求。
我特别同一些老板说的。
就是他
不能不落在实处
就是你
每一个都得是
研制有误的
不能是说
这棋子打出来了
我蹭一波流量
我就走了
我就这样的话
对
所以说到这呢？
我觉得男性跟女性。
对于这个
对方可能会有一些。
差异的
就印象上的
刻板印象
对对对
那我先问一个问题。
就是Mia
你觉得男性
购买户外装备的时候。
跟女性比
最大的不同是什么？
我们先听听
互相的刻板印象
我揣测他们
我觉得就是
特别想
显得自己很厉害
很专业
然后
因为
如果不是这样的话。
去鸟要卖给谁呢？
就是
你都不是军人
你为什么要买
这种
仿军用的装备
我一直都不是很理解。
我觉得他内心
可能是有一个自己。
理想当中的
自己的一个形象
你说的是男性用户是吧？
对 男性消费者
明白
我可太喜欢这节目了。
一开始就是
上奖度是吧？
你要这么说
那我就不客气了
那谢老板
你觉得女生
我先回答他刚才那问题。
对
拜托回去
有的时候
这得说
颜值的问题
或者说
比如说
你说女孩在乎颜值。
男孩在乎
也在乎颜值
就是
男性有的时候会觉得。
或者说
现在这个市场
会觉得说
有个物取
就是觉得
女性用户
可能更在意的是
这个衣服
或者装备的颜值
男性不在意
不是
我觉得这太帅了
你这么说我理解
所谓军事风
机能风
山细户外
这种东西
就是说
它是我们眼中的那个帅。
眼中的颜值高
眼中的情绪价值
比如说
这个对我们男性有误解。
觉得我们不在意
谁说不在意
老在意了
我老喜欢了
我跟你说
我都
到现在我就舍不得买。
你就是觉得真的好看。
我真的喜欢
而且那个衣服
你觉得还好在哪吗？
那个衣服是属于
就是好的
所谓好的半形是啥。
或者是这种男性
男生穿好的半形
好的半形是
它那个衣服
你1米65穿好看。
你1米7穿好看
你1米75穿也好看。
如果就是说这个版。
然后呢？
它会显得你的身材。
比较装
毁物
而且它还是想
显自己厉害
不是
它显自己厉害
也不丢人嘛？
显自己帅
显自己美
显自己厉害
也不丢人嘛？
比如说
女性有的时候
对男性的这种刻板印象。
他觉得那个
不是颜值
但是实际上
我认为那就是颜值。
包括有一些机能风。
我就觉得
那就是颜值
难道就是情价值
我拜托完了
我还有个偏见
你说
2011女性戏
太好了
就是男性特别迷恋参数。
就是有些参数
我觉得其实用不上。
比如说
石祖鸟
七八千的一件那个硬壳。
你天天挤地铁
也用不上啊？
那为什么一定要迷恋。
参数越高的
产品越喜欢呢？
相写的自己厉害
你过问了
既然这样
我就不得不说你们了。
快来吧？
这个我觉得是跟
男性的这种理性的。
所有方式
和女性的感性
所有方式太区别
因为你看女孩
她主要是看这种外观颜值。
包括这个
有些功能性
她会看重这些东西。
男性呢？
其实她会更加的
男性
其实说实话
更能算紧
我就我看看
除了颜值以外
我看我能不能说
我这个别吃亏
我说我在乎那个数据。
我也不是我买到头。
我是要看
谁家的数据更好
谁家的性价比更高。
我选哪个
在乎谁家
我不是在乎数据
而是我觉得数据
或者是说材料
这些东西
是我选择这个产品的。
一个维度
就是实力我也要
外观我也要
就是就是男性
所谓选择这个产品。
或者服装的
理性一点的这种维度。
但是就是说
不好挣钱
老爷们钱不好挣
我就是太能算计了。
就是这种事
那女性可能看着
我就认为
女性看着就好看
别人穿得好看
版型好
或者说材料也不错。
就消费了
这是我的一个感觉。
这是不是我对女性的。
一个误区
不是吧？
这很没有底气的时候。
我觉得
这真是我们理性的部分。
因为我们在
做市场调研的时候。
经常会有一个品牌。
我用的是什么？
Coolmax的面料。
我用的是Sorona的面料。
大家就说
你看他堆料了
他就好
堆料了还便宜
然后这个
我就特别不能理解。
比如说我们女生
我们无所谓
这调什么调牌
大概率
我只要穿上
舒服这不就行了吗？
但我觉得男性
好像对于体验
可能更重视
就是他绝对的
这个数值
不是说
更重视数值
和不重视体验
是你那体验哪来的。
就是举个例子
比如Coolmax。
他的这种
所谓导汉的
这种特性
或者他这种
异形的这种
解面的纤维
他能造成你的这种。
比如说
凉爽也好
素干也好
你跟我说
咱就说别管他真假。
或者他程度高
或者低
你那些啥都没有
你普通面馅的东西。
你跟他这纤维怎么比。
你说你体感好
那你不是胡说的吗？
那他这个东西
他胡说
他有一定根据
说他胡说
他胡说50%
但至少有50%没胡说。
或者30%没胡说。
我觉得他也是OK的。
说我就纯面馅
我纯面的
或者我低伦的
我就能导汉
我就能素干
那你那你那
当然也可以导汉素干。
那你的程度是多少。
你跟这种情况比起来。
他肯定有检验数
检验的这种结果呀？
所以我觉得
不是说他
我们不在意
我们在意
对吧那总得有根据。
你说你导汉素干
你这些
你总有个根据
你不能毛根据没有。
你要敢卖这个
你敢说你这个
欠为是异形解面
你要是敢欺贴消费者。
那你这品牌崩活了。
你可以忽悠我说
你放大这个程度
但你肯定不敢完全作假。
这是我的感觉
但比如说女性去购买。
他更多的在意的是。
上身之后的感觉
上身之前怎么办
上身之前怎么决策。
所以他们就买来
然后退货
这女孩的钱多难赚。
这是我的痛苦
因为我发现
做服装线退货率太高了。
就是因为消费者
是无理有退货的
但其实大家是愿意。
但我观察的就是
女性更愿意试
试完了之后
看看她的感受是什么样的。
这里边还有一个问题。
就是你要试
或者你要体验
它是一个
长时间的体验
三次四次
你穿一次
或者说你在这个场景里边穿。
或者你穿一次
或者说你那个感觉。
可能不明显
咱都在空调红里边穿。
那你的
你所谓这个感受
那她服感更好一点。
那她赢了
那不代表她导汉
或者是苏干能力强。
就所以这个东西
你不能靠
你试啊？
你在家里边试你呢？
你要出去走一圈
对了
有道理
大家已经看到了
很大的区别
那我们再问问谢老板。
你觉得女生跟男生相比。
我们在购买的时候。
有什么？
你觉得特别不一样的地方。
女生跟男生
购买的有些不一样的地方。
是吧？
刚才说男生跟女生是吧？
刚才说男生都误区了。
是吧？
女生
其实就是我刚才说的那个。
我觉得女生可能
这个里边有
我觉得是生理的原因。
或者是说
我觉得女孩呢？
偏理性的不爱算计。
不像男生那么算计。
男生可能恨不得
特别是像我中年男生。
太算计了
只要中登
不叫中年男生
中登
好 又挑起了一轮。
哈哈哈哈
魅力
特别能算计
所以算计的话呢？
就是说
这个钱就不好挣
而且我们有的时候。
对什么妇感
什么卫生
很多东西
但是女孩不是
女孩我觉得对妇感的要求。
比较高
对颜色的要求比较高。
对搭配的要求比较高。
但是呢？
就是说
我为啥那天给你讲。
聊这话题
我是觉得这个
现在目前
很多品牌
就没有太满足
就包括你今天给我。
拿你那个袜子
我就觉得
他就是认为
我就认为这个袜子。
是属于
功能性包括延迟
都满足的东西
但是这个市场上
其实他并不多
这是我现在目前
看到的这个情况
你是觉得市场上是。
延迟的部分满足多少。
还是功能的
延迟的满足
那是
因为谢老板给我
举了个例子说
你看图布鞋
哪有一个稍微好看点的。
女生的图布鞋
图布鞋目前都
确实还挺丑的
实话实说
就图的里边八大个。
说这个还行
但是我拿出来几双。
还行的
我有些女性朋友说。
这就根本就
就不叫好看
就跟好看没有关系。
就是没那么丑
我总体觉得
谢老板说的不是刻板印象。
确实是
就是女生对于
这方面会更在意
那我来跟具体的问问。
比如说以下这些因素。
你们俩排
在购买的时候
排前三的分别是什么？
我会说有场景
功能
舒适度
重量
价格 品牌 颜值 情绪价值。
我先说
女孩先说
秘亚先说
谢老板先说
我想一下
我先说
我觉得她的这个
得先看场景
是什么场景
比如说
咱们
因为秘亚总区这种。
经交
一些比较成熟的线路。
包括有些
非常美的
这种景色的地儿
然后单日的这种场景。
那我觉得
我最在意的就是
比如说是
我那我最在意的就是颜值。
所谓就是情绪价值。
这套活
颜值搭配这个活
然后呢？
如果说
我们要去
有点海拔
有个两三天
三四天
那个条件比较艰苦。
那我就最在意的是功能。
这个两个是
调会调个的
但是呢？
他们虽然调个
但他都属于
第一位第二位的
只不过
在不同的场景里边。
我可能会
他的位置会不一样。
只是排第一的
和第二的
但是他也会篡
第二个是
第三个吧？
第三个是重量和舒适度。
我把重量和舒适度。
放在一起
我觉得
难的就是
最大的区别就是
他最重量在意
但是他没那么在意。
他肯定在意没在意。
一个是舒适度的问题也是。
就是
难的也是
就是你发现他
无所谓
或者说
他负感不明显
所以呢？
我就是重量和舒适度。
是属于排在第二位的。
你说在意
也不能说不在意
但你说特在意
也就那么回事
然后我最不在意的是。
第三个
或者对不起啊？
最不在意的是
第四个和第五个
我最不在意的是
价格和品牌
就是
那这个可能也
跟我的年纪有关
就是因为我就
中年人有的时候
可能买的不多
但是我要买好一点的。
就是我只能买一个。
也可以当我买好一点的。
我希望呢？
对自己好一点也好。
或者有钱花
刀刺上也好
那我可能
是不在意价格太高。
或者是愿意换这种。
功能和愿意换这种舒适度。
是这个啊？
然后品牌跟这个价格。
我就是关联在一起的。
品牌我不在意
我一点不在意品牌。
我没有那个
不好那个面子
我没有那个时候了。
爱什么品牌
他只要好就行
这是我的一二三四的牌位。
我们先来听听Mia。
看看有没有区别
我觉得还是有区别的。
我当然我不能代表。
所有女生
我就是说我自己的感受吧？
我觉得更从我入户外。
这个圈子
入户外这个爱好的。
前后对比吧？
对我前期
作为一个小白的时候。
我期比要在意品牌。
然后我也比较在意颜值。
我那个时候
最大的一个苦脑
就是怎么都这么吵。
然后就不说版型
就是颜色
我都觉得选不到
我觉得好看的颜色。
就是为什么要这么高保合度。
对吧我就去个京郊。
当时候也不需要直升级。
来搜援救援
我也不需要他一眼就看见。
我就是那个时候
我就觉得还是小白的那套想法。
但再往后一点
当我开始走一点长线。
或者开始走得海拔更高的时候。
我就会在意
比方说重量
我会特别在意重量。
因为我背不动
对以及功能
因为我自己
就是你到山上真的被动我。
事交人一次就会
你就知道说
功能性面料
这东西是非常非常重要的。
当然舒适这些
我觉得可能一直都有考量。
但没有那么明显的变化。
说一开始我不重视舒适。
后边我特别重视舒适。
对就是我的回答
我听到这儿反而发现说。
在这个牌序上
男女的差异并不大。
她可能跟场景和
你们户外阶段的这个。
差异性会比较大
那这几年你们觉得。
听到身边的人
在这些选择的趋势上。
有一些什么新的变化吗？
我自己感觉就是
我先说我自己吧？
我现在可能
不会像前期那么在意颜值了。
就是因为我已经习惯了。
习惯了他的丑
就是你妥协了
你不可能要
六边行战时
我一件衣服把功能。
又好又舒适
然后性价比也不促。
还长特漂亮
然后我觉得
我已经放弃了这件事情了。
有没有那种可能
就是你被洗过了
或者你得洗脑了
这个颜色你也觉得。
或者这个造型
我他就是丑
那你还挺棒的
你没有被洗过来了。
我没有被洗过
因为我确定就是
我不知道这套审美是哪来的。
是欧美人觉得这样好看吗？
还是
我相信颜色
是功能的一部分
比如说他就是得鲜艳。
然后我也发现
在户外的时候
你穿鲜艳就是拍起来。
就是好看
这个我也能理解
但我依旧觉得有些颜色。
他没必要
比如说橙色很鲜艳。
一定要那个橙色吗？
就是这种感觉
他就是
我觉得还是来自于。
去欧美的
这种审美
然后过来
对
不加思考的就采用了这些。
大蓝大红什么的
包括橙色这种东西。
他确实颜色
这种显得粗暴
就是颜色那个红
说实话
这梅红是不是也叫红呢？
对
是不是也好看呢？
也能看见对吧？
直升级也能看见
对对对
这个绿是不是也好看呢？
但是那套东西
还是来自于
欧美的这种审美体系。
像尼卡龙
他们就是老美
就是喜欢那种
蓝色那种红色
他就是喜欢
他和橙色也是一样的。
他这个东西
跟那个功能性
确实有关系
但是实际上
你看现在国内
做这些服装
设计师这些颜色
什么的
已经开始有很大变化了。
实际上
已经有这种
浅粉色的冲锋衣了。
对
包括国内的品牌
像凯勒什也有这种。
梅红色的
或者是紫色的这种冲锋衣。
对对对
就这颜色属于
又好看
又有识别度
但是他需要时间
是
就咱们都是
老美人
他们过来的这种东西。
对
就所以我就想说
我现在可能
你说有什么变化吗？
我对颜值有变化
我对颜值要求
没那么高了
妥协了妥协了
以及就是
玩得越多越开始
对重量在意了
轻量化很重要
可能我也走不了多少。
然后我走的那个强度。
你多个一公斤
可能也没那么大的影响。
但是我就觉得
我要追求这个
进阶
不是小百万家
别闹
你这都多自身了
我再说说
男性的变化
男性其实
像我们之前
说实话
真是不在意颜色
不在意
搭配也不在意造型。
你又吵架我们
你也露出了什么？
习惯的表情
他的意思是
好像是我们现在
有在意的
被说中了
我们是
原来是不在意
现在
也没有
肯定不会像女性那么在意。
但是开始在意一点了。
在意那一点
可能搭配的不好
可能颜色选不好
但是他在意
就是我开始
关注自己感受了
可能就
我不知道你们啥感觉。
反正我们这种
就是挣钱
努力一百
养家
干活
就是你说你要有
太多的心思
你回去
随意说实话
晚上特累
你两点钟到家
你连个早都不想洗。
你还说我还
搭配个衣服
不可能
但是现在呢？
就属于啥呢？
一个是
也不太挣钱了
对吧？
没扎心
你看经济下行
有好处
大家神魅上来
另外一个呢？
开始觉得说
可能在
你说你又能有几年活呢？
每年
过两年可能也就没了呢？
对不对
还有一个说
很多东西都是天命。
对吧？
孩子老婆家人
他自己有自己的命。
很多东西你也不能左右的。
就放松了一点
那就对自己更好一点。
真的
我也照顾照顾自己情绪。
既然外界的工作
没那么多
然后呢？
家里人的这种状态。
也还OK
那就这么着
就开始关注
你说我们得
需要学习
跟
能说Gay吗？
可以
我们跟Gay
跟女孩比起来
就是
那就是在穿搭这件事。
或者在这个神魅这件事。
他不是说
同一个物种
高低的事
他是不同的物种
就我们就是
咱不能说
望自匪
真是低一点
很难的
谢老板这段
真的很有深度
就是你一下子
回到了说
这个大的经济环境下。
直男们的
就是中年直男们的。
这种出门
或者说生活状态
我觉得的确是在
美的这个关注度上的。
集中化程度
可能会比你刚说到的。
一些同性人士
或者说说女性
可能我觉得
会稍微少一些
因为花的经历
可能会少一些
这也是一个
实在的情况
对 但听你们这么说完。
我觉得
哇 这个
差异非常的大
但是为了让这个听众们。
更加有具体的实感。
我们接下来玩一个游戏。
我们从0开始来
制办一套装备
把你们家那些都忘记。
家里都没有任何装备。
但是我当时出题的时候说。
一万块钱
我不知道够不够你俩花。
咱俩可以
你们俩可以那个
说一个数
比如说我们多少钱。
从0开始配备一套。
五天穿西徒步的
全部装备
然后你们会怎么花。
这个钱
我们就说一万块钱吧？
是清徒步还是
对 重装嘛？
不用的
不用买帐篷
不用买市面系统
不然一下子钱就没了。
就清装的
就是有马夫背
对
OK
当然如果你不愿意。
睡这个领队提供的帐篷。
睡袋你也可以买
反正
反正就一万
你自己看着办
够不够
够不够是吧？
你先住我先住
家里总有一两件
能用的吧？
就完全从0开始
完全从0开始
之所以问这题
也有个原因是
我们有很多小白的听众。
大家也很想知道
说我第一次去徒步。
到底配置什么？
你们俩有这么多的经验。
也给大家一些参考。
我先说
我抛砖影域
对
我肯定是会买好的鞋子。
好的徒步鞋
然后我会买保暖的衣服。
羽绒娃
或者是防风的
像冲锋衣这些
我觉得就是
一定要需要的几个。
硬性的装备
除此以外
我可能
我会想买个
比较好的防晒的帽子。
女生怕晒得太黑
怕皮肤受伤
对
我觉得这三样
这四样
是我不会妥协
买什么品贴
不好的产品
当然也不一定都买鸟。
我有没有那个意思。
可能冲锋衣买个
确实它是个专业的冲锋。
一卡农的
我觉得专业冲锋衣也很好。
对
但其他的东西
我刚刚还是跟老柴。
确认说
家里一件都不能用。
我觉得裤子
可能我不会
以上来买
特别好的徒步裤
因为好的也挺贵的。
这一万块钱
肯定是不够
我可能就会穿个
瑜伽裤
然后我可能
或者是我运动
宽松腆的运动裤
然后能相对比较耐磨的。
不容易被刮伤的
我不会穿个
正似的裤子这种裤子出门。
对
但是家里我觉得多少。
我们普通人家
还是有一些衣服
是可以用的
然后包括打底层和中层。
你就速干的
体许一件都没有吗？
我觉得也不至于
我可能会在这几样上面。
滑起
还有一个
我比较需要的是登山帐。
我会买个好的登山帐。
对
就这几个硬性的需要。
明白
那我说我的了
看看男的和女的
有什么区别
期不期待
哈哈哈
非常期待
卖个裤子
我是这样
我这
我其实一半不先花不了。
啊？
还不了
可能我如果说
我认为一套非常合理的。
也就是人五千块钱。
都到不了
首先第一个就是
一个两千块钱的
高帮徒步鞋
也一定是两千块钱左右的。
看我们都买徒步鞋。
而且是
一千五到两千之间的。
你说一不到位了
现在很多鞋都已经。
非常好了
一千五到两千
意大利牌子都可以。
这两千块钱
然后再加上
一个两百到三百的。
羊毛的土布挂
两千
二的两千三了
好舍得在袜子上花钱。
脚步滑了很难
对 这是这个
然后还有一个是
一个一百块钱
到两百块钱的
一个超轻的一个羽衣。
不要买那种泡炸羽衣。
一百到两百之间
那个超轻泡炸羽衣。
超轻羽衣
不买一次性羽衣
买一次性的
甚至要买轻的
那一百到两百
对 一百到两百之间的。
其他的全买最便宜的。
只有这三样花钱
花的比较
我就是到头
其他的东西全是最便宜的。
中锋衣抵抗弄五百块钱。
六百块钱
买了一个
还没说五百
然后什么打底
抓容 全买最便宜的。
裤子
随便一个素杆的裤子。
都可以
包括那个帽子
这都不重要
只有我认为这个
这三样吧？
是叫花到头
其他东西全不所谓。
一步到位
因为它
这个三个东西
会给你未来的体验。
比如体验
会增加很大的
这种数十度
有时候鞋和袜子这东西。
其实我认为
就是最重要的这个。
你买个包
你买随便背一个包。
你把孩子上学那包背的东西。
对
对吧？
一个清装东西
背多少东西
背点水
你能有啥背部系统。
没有
一个鞋
你穿五天
这五天
你那个脚步
肯定是疲劳了
你不买高帮
你买低帮
你容易崴脚
到第四五天的时候。
你依然能够给你
让你稳定住你的脚踝。
你都一周都没劲了。
到四五天的时候
所以高帮这是必须的。
袜子太重要了
是一个又重要
又不起眼
又被人忽视的东西。
你不能摸起泡
你必须偷气
咱们比如说
有味我觉得都是放在最后了。
包括你的
难得
对吧？
心里话又说出来了。
对
我们不再味道
或者说你要买那种。
羊毛的袜子
其实还好
没那么夸张
所以200-300块钱。
那基本上就是最好的袜子了。
你那袜子150一个。
是吧？
买两双
300块钱
因为我们的150三个。
150三个是吧？
那你150三个
对吧？
就够了
而且我也不认为
要买100%羊毛的。
35%的就OK了。
就够了
对
就把袜子和鞋做好。
就完事了
它会帮你做减震
黄磨
不起水泡
然后不跟鞋有摩擦。
这是我认为
羽衣是什么呢？
因为你不带羽衣肯定不行。
不带冲锋衣也不行。
冲锋衣在那种情况下。
有的时候你需要透气。
你不是说你一旋穿一衣。
那就废了
一身汗
你要穿冲锋衣
因为大量的时间
你可能需要行走
它有的时候
动态的
对
偶尔要下雨
你说那如果天暖活了。
它不下雨了行不行。
那你脱了不就完了吗？
你连衣服都能穿
打底就可以了
所以呢就是这么一个。
就是只要这几样花的贵。
冲锋衣都买最便宜的。
500块钱
600块钱
对吧？
打底
那个什么UTO都不有的事。
那个一辆百块钱一套那个嘛？
没有他们家还是挺贵的。
挺不贵
那你再选那个不知名的。
还盘的
这个东西就是
到100多200多人。
这种100多200多打底一套的。
没有任何技术含量了。
所有的牌子都可以了。
对
它就是一件苏干了。
对 是吧？
你说保暖的东西
你带个抓容
带个排骨玉笼
你也没多少钱
两三百块钱
三四百块钱
最多了就是
帽子
你随便了就
最多裤子
我觉得这些东西
穿一条我们平时穿。
只要不是棉的有点酷。
底轮的那种苏干的也好。
或者就是那种都可以啊？
连五千块钱都划不上。
哇 我听下来觉得。
这个差异太大了
其中我觉得
一样的就是脚步的投资。
对
你们俩就觉得非常重要。
我也是这么建议的。
我觉得脚势非常重要。
然后
谢老板提到
雨衣的确是非常男性向的。
一个建议
但是我身边
几乎所有的这个男性的。
五大老都也是建议。
雨衣其实比
尤其是大雨的时候。
那冲冲雨肯定是挨不住的。
那肯定还是雨衣比较好。
然后我没想到的一个差异是。
米娅非常重视帽子。
防山帽
但其实谢老板
还有保暖
刚刚像对谢老板觉得说。
排骨他多少
两三百块钱
三四百块钱
我想
我不行
发容
快来讲讲
你觉得帽子和
我觉得这个方面
也有一个就是
我们男性女生理上的区别。
女性天然就体温低。
就是怕冷
所以保暖对我来说。
真的很重要
然后
我觉得像
我要买一个雨龙斧的话。
因为雨龙这个东西。
它就是
它这个生产过程还是相对。
有那么一点点残忍的。
所以我可能会希望。
这个东西我是一步到位。
买一个我能用很久的。
好的雨龙
我可能不会去
有一库这种地方
买一个超轻的排骨雨龙斧。
我可能就会买一个。
很专业的
好的品牌的雨龙
上来就顶配
雨龙我就想买顶配。
这个确实是这样
我的感受也区别很大。
就是
因为我是一个尽量。
希望那个性价比
比较高的人
但是
价格差异大的
雨龙斧的体感
真的差异很大
就现在有两个怕冷的人。
对
有很多这种
大品牌
我们就
这会儿先不具名了。
有些大品牌的
这种超轻雨龙斧
因为它是
可能有一库的
十倍的价格
但它穿上真的
会暖和很多
你看
这就是说
说到这个男性的
这个理性视角了
男性就是很简单
你不管什么品牌
你看它充重量
蓬松度
容子含量
你看它这些东西
看它这些指标
清洁度
这些东西只要摆在这。
它不敢骗人
有国标
它们会有点
那个就是说
抱得稍高一点
或者缠一点甲
但是它不会缠太多。
但比如说
它声称自己是八百棚。
这边声称是七百棚。
那应该贵多少
合适呢？
七百棚八百棚是这样。
这些七百棚八百棚。
包括六百五
我自己认为
你看你的价格
你自己有多少钱
你有多少钱
你多少钱预算
你就顶头买就行了。
不是说你七百棚八百棚。
那就是它八百棚
是挺合适的
那肯定比那好
但是问题是
你这四百块钱五百块钱。
你要干啥
你就可是你那钱
预算
然后你刚刚说的帽子。
我也没有想到
在你必买的装备里面。
你把帽子提得这么高。
对
我刚想一下
我一开始买的时候。
就是鱼龙夫买了一个。
很好的牌子
然后帽子我一直在。
寻觅好用的牌子
就这儿我们也不说。
具体品牌了
对
就是因为我觉得
他的那个感受非常明显。
他还
他就是在你头上
是个鱼肤帽吗？
对
你得牙儿够大
是个鱼肤帽
对
大的遮阳帽
鱼肤帽的那种
对
类型吧？
那个帽型
首先是我觉得他
要真的很遮阳
其次是
其次是他带起来
很轻
很舒服
透气
然后
比方说去传席
会不会下雨那几天。
要不要带防雨的帽子。
防水的
防泼水的帽子
或者是就是直接上。
防雨面料的帽子
然后他好不好折迪。
有没有挂绳
然后跟我这套
好不好搭配之类的。
我对帽子
特别重要的
我对帽子的要求
真的是很高的
两位还没有提到
我跟你们大体相似。
但是有一个你们
跟你们不一样的点。
就是背包
因为刚刚谢老板
提到说背包
其实背一个差不多的就行。
我跟谢老板
同样的意见
但是我在山里面
比如说走10公里。
比如说爬山
大概在500一千的时候。
我就觉得
这个背包
好得和不好的
给我的肩膀的压力。
会非常非常大
所以哪怕说
我就背一个30升。
我可能也想找一个。
首先他超轻
第二他有背负系统的。
所以我觉得背包
我也会比较在意
但是有个原则是啥呢？
比如说我其实觉得。
30升就算大包了。
30升就大包吗？
对
你要去穿西
我个人觉得
你背不了那么多东西。
单日二十是吧？
背不了那么多东西。
那马扑都帮你背着呢？
你自己就背点
吃了背点水
你背个保暖衣物
你还想背点电子产品。
对不对
相机三个加起来
就很重要
谁突破第一次背相机。
对吧？
那我是觉得
30升就算大包了。
30升那就是很大了。
但是要有点小背负系统。
明白
然后还有一个
我刚才最强调的那个就是。
它不要超过5000块钱。
别人都问这种问题了。
那肯定是时间玩的不久。
很多东西都是刚开始玩。
你先不超过5000块钱。
你先买
有些必要的东西
你买好的
然后后边你觉得
你想再比如说帽子。
或者背包
我就想在这提升
那你在单独买的东西。
合理
对
搭配颜色
你再搭
有什么你觉得
你特别不在意的装备。
或者就一万块钱
你会怎么分配
我也是
鞋袜肯定是第一
因为我觉得太重要了。
而且袜子
我之前一直有个建议。
就建议大家
多待几个
对 要一定要换一次。
这样的话保持脚步的干爽。
就不会起泡之类的。
然后
从袜子往上的东西。
其实都没有那么重要了。
但是我觉得背包
对我比较重要
会让我稍微舒服一点。
对
是这样
那我们接下来玩的这个游戏。
我估计听众会特别喜欢。
因为我们刚在这个环节里面。
没有提及品牌
接下来我就更具体一点。
请大家敞开了了
各种品牌
各种型号
没有任何禁忌的
欢迎大家推荐
因为我是想通过
不同品类的推荐和吐槽。
来让大家看看
男女选择的区别
我们先从什么开始呢？
先从大件
冲锋衣保暖层
好不好
就是
比如说
米亚和谢老板
你们之前穿过的
冲锋衣保暖层里面。
可以推荐一到三款。
吐槽一到三款
推荐三款
吐槽也有三款
对
代品牌代型号都行。
只要对方不至于
会跟我们打官司的那种机器。
都行
你去确定那啥吗？
吐槽的时候
可以引去品牌
你打上那个
可以
我们有那个功能
推荐
我
冲锋衣一上来
就买了一个顶配
怎样的
鸟家的Alpha。
一上来就顶配了
什么颜色的
买的还是线两款
黑色的一个
然后
反正就是说
就是
调研了一下市场
说这就差不多
第一梯队产品了
我就想说那行
我用一下
我知道冲锋衣
最好的是什么样
我以后大概
我再买冲锋衣
我去店里试一下
我就知道
怎么样了
还是有钱
没有
我当时就是
我觉得这个咱们一会。
可以聊的时候
可以吐槽一下
我觉得我是被很多。
社交媒体误导了
就一上来
就跟人家也被误导。
人家在那边买Alpha。
不是
我不是被具体的
引导到了某个品牌。
某个型号
我是觉得
小白不要上来
就买冲锋衣
你用不上
你又不去六千米海吧？
就像谢老板说的
其实可能
你就买个雨衣够用了。
你甚至就
对
不去太威胁的地方。
一次性雨衣也行
对
所以冲锋衣这块
我没有什么？
特别想要吐槽的品牌。
你必须吐槽
有点贵
品牌
具体的冲锋衣的品牌。
品牌或者设计都可以。
你说宣传
我觉得设计上
可以说一下
好多冲锋衣
因为他
我没看过他那个男款。
女款有什么差别
除了颜色不同
我没觉得那版型上。
有什么具体的差异。
然后
加上刚才我们聊到。
他很多审美
或者设计理念
是来自于欧美的那一套。
所以他绣的就是
巨长无比
虽然我也知道
他冲锋衣可能是
为了攀冰
或者什么样
他绣的就是要
做的长一点
但是是不是也太长了。
我对版型
对冲锋衣的版型
是有一些小吐槽的。
有些品牌是可以免费财的。
是吗？
可以养
你踩到正上去
明白
没了
OK
他没有吐槽
那个产品
是不是
和那个品牌是不是。
对
你哪怕这个产品
不值得吐槽一下
太好了
就喜欢隐占的环节。
二方
二方你都不敢吐槽吗？
二方有啥吐槽的
我没觉得有
需要吐槽
你二方SV对吗？
对
我觉得他的点是
他不是说
那个产品要被吐槽。
而是说这个产品
他就不是说
普通人用得上
应该穿的
对
我是真看过有些人穿。
而且他去吐槽下那种线路去穿。
我就会觉得
我说你来这儿穿这个衣服。
除了彰显自己的这个。
小老板
你找了我一眼
除了彰显自己的这个。
财富
或者品费
或者是说这种
社交货币
装插
对吧？
这个东西在这种场景里边。
只有不好的点
没有好的点
因为他可能
广湖性更强
更重更温暗
那你可能
你在五千米六千米。
你再需要他
那这个就在这个场景里面。
就显得特别的奇怪。
对吧？
而且还是一个
限量版的配色
你其实想吐槽我
是吧？
我听出来了
但是我确实在
在吐槽下
看到有人穿这个
没啥必要
他可能穿的是普天尿。
真的
我还问他
他说是真的
他当然说是真的
他能跟你说
我刀包三百块买的吗？
因为他穿了别的
我一看
我说你这个
所有衣服你都配的。
都是最顶配的
最顶配的
但实际上
就是那个线路
包括他的这个
他可能的
我回家走一半
所以你对SV的
吐槽就是他可能
在有些场景下
太重太闷了
太厚了
他产品本身
是优秀产品
那这个产品
能这么经典
比如说高海拔
他不能说最牛吧？
都是一T对
但是呢？
他在换在
这个场景里边
很多普通人的场景里边。
他就是一个
不合适的东西
甚至是增加负担的东西。
所以其实是吐槽
这个产品有些
错误的使用场景
没错
或者说有些错误的引导。
你错过引导
对
有可能
比如说电源
他想承担
然后说你要去
虎跳下说
那也可以穿
可以穿
你这个就一步
都为了哥
你这当哪
你说你三千两千
你五千你不能
都能穿它吗？
再说这玩意现在卸量。
那有什么？
微妙微笑的
我觉得这也是
目前的一个
大的线上
就是功能荣誉
好多人觉得
它是向下兼容的
但其实不是什么回事。
当你的防水
吸收特别高的时候。
它的透气肯定就不行了。
这是为什么？
还不如穿一件羽衣呢？
因为羽衣
你继续防水
也不叫绝对防水
非常防水
但是你也可以方便。
拿下来之后
你就可以透气吗？
还长
对
所以功能荣誉
的确是一个问题
主要是它在
那个场景里边
它重
它要厚
它模块好它
一百滴的应该是
但正常穿
对吧？
咱们穿
比如说
三领地
它的一百滴
它的特后
它就怕你万一
有问题的时候
它模块了
它所以它面料以后。
你也觉得重
你负担大
所以我觉得
就没那么合适
在场景里边
但是有人觉得
它是情绪价值
那这就不一样了
社交护币
他觉得这个
不是人
没什么感觉
因为没怎么动
所以就没什么事
这感觉是
新一波吐槽
长得很深
没怎么动
我怎么动
是啥意思
我就说
因为它们有的时候。
它走的距离
没那么大
没怎么出汗
所以它感受不到
这种感觉
那我倒过说了
是吧？
那你都说
十公小了
我必须得说
国内两个品牌
初末一
一个是那个
凯勒石的
这个是现在
我认为
非常好
口碑之王
还有一个
它的颜色非常多
是那个你说
那个紫色的那个吗？
有紫色
有什么颜色
反正一堆颜色
它的颜色多
就是女孩
现在没什么？
很多年轻人和女孩。
愿意买的
就是因为它叫它配色好看。
它更接近
包括宇宙府也是
更接近于
这个
咱们亚洲人的审美。
包括对色彩的
这种感受
东亚的这种感受
这是这个
还有一个是
颜色虽然没那么多。
但是性能其实很强。
就是那个
贪录者那个
MX33
还有PRO
就是他这个也是很好。
就是这几款国内的产品。
就是别的产品
咱就不说了
咱就说这两个产品。
绝对是国内
初末一里面
就是这个
谢老板说说
我都很感动
奇迹皮疙瘩
你是不知道我之前。
也在贪录者过对吧？
我不知道
对
所以我觉得
贪录者其实是
一个目前被
非常低估的品牌
尤其他的HiMax系列。
我觉得
能说出
贪录者HiMax的人。
是就是
专业当中的责任
对
这个能回头发给
同事
这期可散出一箱
但是因为
HiMax真的是花了。
贪录者
最核心的
科研心血
跟登山队
跟西藏登山队
联合研发的产品
这一套产品
我们穿了之后
都觉得极好无比
但是其实
它的性价比非常高。
但它的绝对单价
也比较高
是因为
它用到的
科技面料
和整个这个
研发的周期都非常的长。
HiMax所有的产品。
都非常非常顶
就是整个
西藏登山队的修路队。
穿的全是这一款
包括南北级科考队。
他们的核心的
这个站上的
工程师
穿的也都是HiMax系列。
但是这个产品
我觉得很可惜
就你营销没做好
我听懂了
是
我觉得还是有时机。
就是那个时候
可能还是早
我们的这种
民族自信各方面
得慢慢来
所以我想问
这个系列现在还有吗？
有
所以特别推荐大家。
在打折的时候
发现这款要是打折的话。
这个系列
必入款
好好好
还有一个是什么呢？
就是
有的时候
就带大家关注
一个单品的时候呢？
这个品牌
它一段时间
给它推起来了
它就会跟着就起来了。
像Montex不知道。
好像凯勒士他们
那个产品就是这么个情况。
就是跟上了
这个风口
就一起起来了
然后HiMax这个。
三三这个呢？
它就
它怎么说呢？
就是在这个
冲锋衣这个品内
在启示的时候
它没有跟上这个节奏。
是机上可能
是的
你看现在
它就会等于什么呢？
就会被
比如说像薄熙盒
或者凯勒士
或者像很多品牌
在做这种市场
做的量比较大的情况下。
就把那个信息
就给淹没掉了
但是呢？
这个衣服非常的好。
这个是非常好的
但是呢？
我得说他们缺点
来 接着出草
他们的缺点什么呢？
因为他们的产品本身。
比较好
他们的单价
就会显得非常的贵。
比如说
大家不知道
但是大家知道
它是价格贵
你说你凭什么？
卖3600
你凭什么？
3600啊？
具体价格我不知道。
不好意思
对吧 你看
你听到这个价格
你就觉得贵吗？
不贵
冲锋衣嘛？
冲锋衣
你说最顶的两件
冲锋衣了
3000多
普通老百姓
买个1500
1523的
这是大有人在
3000多
那这就属于
高档冲锋衣了
他说那我都买
3000多了
我给他买个
啥牌子
对对对
在牌子上
对吧？
但是实际上
你要是同样品质
你要买别的牌子
或者大点牌子
或者买个鸟
或者像什么的
那基本上就是
4000 5000 6000。
7000 8000。
就这么个情况了
对
所以它还是性价比高。
但是显得单价贵
对
没错
而且还有一个就是。
很多人会觉得说
你这国产牌子
是的
都还这么贵啊？
包括
凯乐是这两年
提价这个事
对 这个我也不太理解。
为什么要吐槽
为什么国牌不能卖贵。
我觉得咋了
我们不能挣点一价吗？
就是
而且我感觉男性吐槽比较多。
怎么说呢？
其实你知道吐槽是什么意思吗？
就是挑货才是买货人。
就比如说
我其实吐槽的意思。
就是很明显
我就行
我就知道你咋个事。
你能不能便宜点
你要能便宜点
我就消费了
对吧？
但我能不能
通过这种方式
我说你这太贵
你国产牌子卖这么贵啊？
就因为打折
现在六折
来一个
但是他们不打折
这一点是我
见过很那什么的
我不知道
那Himex打不打折。
Himex也几乎不打折。
就是不说有打折
我就说万一如果碰到。
对 就是他们这种产品。
他不太打折
这是我见到的
我不知道现在不打折。
但是我以前知道的是不太打折。
我听说的是不打折。
我跟大家说
行业机密
比如说以Himex为例。
他为什么不打折
因为一般产品的倍率。
我们指的倍率
比如说他出厂裸价是。
随便说假设是一千块钱的产品。
他乘以一般六倍
六千块钱卖
但是Himex
他卖你三千块钱的时候。
他的成本可能是一千五。
那就有两倍倍率
所以没法打折
他没法打折
所以他的性价比是非常高。
太好了
L10那个衣服
他也是这个意思
倍率低
他没有那么高利润。
而且还有一个
他这种产品
可能从我的角度来讲。
这就是
所谓这个品牌的
杀手机产品
我就拿它来换市场了。
那我的利润率不在这出。
我可能利润率打底那出。
在其他的保暖那出。
我现在不确定
那个戏老板说的这款。
是不是我去年
想买的那个紫色那款。
但是我当时的感觉是。
我是说凯勒斯
是不是在做饥饿营销。
怎么一直断货
这个颜色怎么一直断货。
做的少
一批货做的少
行吧？
那可能这也算一个槽点。
货量做大点
但是你看他
就不就掉起了
大家的心里
有那种轻量化的办法。
是R1
还是什么？
R2反正有一些那种东西。
但我卖过
他也好几个抓容
他有些抓容太厚了。
你说那个毛红那种是。
毛红也好
或者是有些那种
像Snap T
像这种的
就是他本身比较厚。
他不太适合
像我们出去徒步啊穿。
我认为早期的时候。
很多人会拿他穿
他是个优秀产品
但现在其实有大量的这种。
叫轻量化抓容
因为屁绵也有
屁绵有屁绵
包括那个Polite。
也有他那个Alpha容。
包括还有很多Octa的那种。
反正就是
市场上大量这种
轻量化抓容
本身就又轻又薄
然后又透气又更强。
他就现在我认为
出去徒步或者干嘛？
我是基本上会带这种抓容的。
就不太会带像那种传统的。
像巴达格加那种厚抓容的。
一个是压缩的体积。
又压缩不下去
重量又挺重
然后呢他的保暖性能。
他其实就能回事
但是我感觉他那一套。
厚的抓容
现在是风格化产品。
因为你看他官网上的模特。
也都不是看着像是运动员。
他就是比较东亚点。
有些日本日潮风
日潮风
潮流了
是的 是的 他是走潮流风的。
对 那这个我觉得。
这个是可以的
他的整个外观还是很漂亮。
或者是有点复古的。
这种潮牌的感觉
可能他现在就是很潮牌的感觉。
走的是这种比较潮流的感觉。
但是你看那个Black Diamond。
还是一直是比较专一线的。
只是我的感觉
OK
中间层
过来没什么想吐槽的。
你先说快一个
你刚不是特别说
哎 我有
女性
是不是见望啊？
就已经说完了
因为我就一直觉得。
我不太喜欢把他给妮娅家的东西。
所有
可能只有一两个
那个素杆
他们出来做的特别好。
我觉得那行吧？
但其他的我都觉得。
性价比很低
然后也很难看
毛红
毛红就是像你说
是风格化产品
以及他太重穿搭了。
你得搭出那个感觉。
他才行
那单品本身拿出来。
我觉得没什么亮眼。
但是这样
他们的品牌
我估计有一种
自己的价值观
他也不希望卖太多。
那应该也
跟经济商没关系
经济商是不一样的。
经济商肯定喜欢卖太多了。
但是我觉得品牌
我觉得这是营销化数。
是吗？
那你把网站关了
你不想卖太多
他肯定想卖他
那我要把所有的收入。
捐给地球
你也你控制
控制
叫我
以上内容
我们全都不会欺负。
如果有律师好
请直接发给米娅
哎呀？
你别这么说
中国不敢说了
保暖层
其实我前面
就是盛赞的
我说那个
拍过羽绒时代
非常好穿的
就是我之前在节目里面。
夸过好多次的
就是茅台他们家的。
Mount的那个。
羽绒服
好暖啊？
包包一件
他现在已经成了
所以我觉得
其实你看他的蓬松度。
可能比别人也差不多。
但是不知道为什么？
就是很暖和
他这里边
除了蓬松度以外呢？
还有有容子弹量
还有他那个是俄容。
还是压容
对
容管大小还不一样。
以及他那个
里边是不是
他怎么？
分区方式
对
相体呢是那种
它是因为
它要砸一根线吗？
它是那种
卡型的
有的呢？
它卡型的话
它就会挤压你的
边缘上的羽绒
它不蓬松了
它这个缝线方式嘛？
有的枪体呢？
是这种方式的
或者是这种机型的。
它在这种排列方式。
就会很少的挤压里面。
比如说你同样
有100克的羽绒。
那如果是这个方式呢？
你至少有10克
是浪费的嘛？
这个意思
所以它
枪体不一样
容子还不一样
有的容子大
有的容子小
对吧？
蓬松度都是这些
它这个蓬松度
都是这些
对吧？
它可能比如说
它的容子大小不一样。
而且呢？
还有一个就是
这里边天充的呢？
如果都是容子的话。
比较好
容子越多也好
如果里边有一些
什么非丝毛片
它不保暖
这没有蓬松度的东西。
它天充的30%在里边。
或者天充的20%在里边。
那肯定不如
就是95%都是
这种容子的
更保暖
你看这都是
大
各种大
蓬松度很高
但实际上
这里边它的这种
有很多操作的空间。
现在在这儿
我问一个问题
就是这两年
国内特别神话
俄容
但是欧洲呢？
有一个风格
就是越来越多的品牌。
不用俄容了
他们用那种
压容
而且是灰压容
翻压容
对
而且他们宁愿用那种。
相对透明的
缝织物
你看这里边的
那个颜色
对对对
然后我们
后来在做消费者调研的时候。
很多中国消费者
就退货了
说你看你这里面
是灰压容
而且这梗子
都能看见
所以就是
在保暖上
有多少区别
以及这种灰压容
和看起来白白的
压容之间
有多少的区别呢？
我说的
如果不对的话
大家可以纠正
他首先
他平时去骂他
但都骂我
是吧？
不好使
压容
其实它一个是
鸭子是杂食性动物。
它有味
而且压容
它那个卤子
小
俄容
它俄容的卤朵大
而且俄容味道小
你不是说没味
可能鸭子肯定味大。
俄什么也白一些
灰压容都有
都有
然后还有一种
翻压容
你说的是鸭子
它就跟俄差不多
挺大一只鸭子
那种的
它也算压容
但是它的卤朵更大。
它接近于它俩之间。
好多高薪压比的
愿意用这个东西
价格没那么贵
但是它卤朵都比较大。
不说发压容
是说
俄容和压容
它的区别
灰压容和压容
和白压容
灰压容和白压容
它的保暖性能是一样的。
无非是好不好看
就是咱们这帮人
有的时候会有一个什么问题呢？
比较在意外观
就是这个意思
原来不是还比较
灰压容和白压容吗？
现在不比较
就是俄容和压容吗？
就是那个灰压容
会这样
灰压容显得会
有点脏
你不管怎么着
你看到那个
如果那个面料很薄。
你看到就是显得有点脏。
对
但是它保暖性能是一样的。
但如果说
我觉得
欧洲这么做
很大一部分
原因是因为
我觉得是环保
我认为
如果你说
你都奔着这个来
都要这个好看的
那你的
所谓成品率
又会很少吗？
那你得干掉
多少只鹅
你才能斩出这点东西来。
大家别追求那个
直接就来了
而且还有
好像欧洲人
不太在意这种外观。
挖子起个球
衣服什么磨破了
或者怎么样
好像欧美人
我不太
不能瞎说
反正他们不太在意。
比我们更糟一点
我们还是比较在意说。
外观
或者别太容易磨破。
这是我们的感觉
我听说
非正式的一个传言。
就是现在全球的
俄容
绝大部分
已经转到中国来了。
还是以中国
作为消费主体
但是欧洲
我们现在接触过的客户。
使用俄容的比例
我看着是在逐年下降的。
大家可能用压容比较多。
包括我刚刚说到的。
可能看到那种梗的。
会压容
甚至更愿意让你看到。
这个材料的
会越来越多
我对刚刚说
这段一会儿
可以放到里面去
就是那个保暖层
我一直特别喜欢的。
一个保暖层是
羽绒马甲
但是我不喜欢排骨马甲。
我不喜欢排骨羽绒。
我觉得特别难看
虽然去年
特别火
有很多潮牌都出了。
但不在我的神媒典上。
我特别喜欢
我当时买过的是
Pink Performance他们家。
出的一个羽绒马甲。
我觉得特别使用
你既冷的时候
你可能套在抓容外边。
做个核心
去干部分的保暖
甚至是再冷的时候。
你外边再套个羽绒符。
再套个外边的冲锋衣。
封壳什么的
把它穿在里面
它薄薄的
又能当最外层穿
又能当中间层穿
我觉得特别使用
而且它是马甲
所以你其实
比方说你夜下透气。
然后你散热
它就会比你穿
整个长袖的一个羽绒符。
要更使用一些
但我发现好像
很多人大家
买中间层的时候
就喜欢直接上个羽绒符。
就不太考虑马甲这个品类。
我也特别喜欢
我那件被我去羽绒符。
涂不涂的时候穿坏。
磨破了
我就又买了一件
我也有这个同样感受。
就是马甲真的很方便。
因为你煮去干暖和之后。
其实四肢问题不会太大。
对 而且它很实用。
你不一定要在户外穿。
天气冷的时候
有时候你坐办公室冷。
你就把它拿出来套上。
特别方便
但是我有个问题
就是非排骨的马甲。
它折叠起来
或者收纳起来
会不会稍微变大
它只是不是排骨的缝线。
它还是 它用了自己的一些。
那个图形
对 去做的缝线
不过它有点有角度。
一块一块的
灵形的一些图啊 这样子。
可能不是那种
一个枪一样
对对对
有些人或者鞋子排裂。
或者是碎一点
对对对
有一个意思
我就不买马甲
这是男女的区别吗？
我不知道是不是男女区别。
我问问马甲这东西就属于。
我认为他
这个马甲属于什么？
过度截断的产品
就比如说女性怕冷。
我觉得需要马甲的时候。
我就不需要了
走起来我会
那如果说再冷一点。
我觉得它那个
这穿有容处了
中间的过度截断我不需要。
对对对
我觉得是可能就是。
我可能希望这个
体温的调节
不是那么大开大合的。
可能两度三度的
这样去调
我热立刻能拖一件。
冷立刻能穿一个小东西。
而且我还嫌麻烦
对 是
你说才会
再麻烦
我说坚持才走
坚持走一下
坚持不了一点
你对等等
我要换衣服
就是除了
我是热了我不等
冷了我基本上
就是微微的冷
我是无所谓的
甚至有点冷不都OK。
没那么的
我怕热不怕冷
我出汗我就必须
马上得换裤子
我真是在
我甚至在户外
经常干我那种事
大不对争走着
我穿那种
比如包暖裤子
太热了
我现场直接拖了
我也不管那么多了。
我怕再出汗就不行了。
包括那个
有时候有女性的
这种用户
我说你赶紧换
你要找个说说
怎么着
你把裤子拖了
要不你这个
你会出汗你会有问题。
是的
所以看大家的耐受度。
和这个场景
还是有一些区分
我们讲完
冲冲一个保暖层
现在第二个重磅了。
我们讲讲徒步鞋吧？
整个鞋泪
行
你们先来推荐兔草。
我先推荐吧？
我比较喜欢的
一个是Hokka的鞋子。
一个是Altra。
我现在基本上
就这两个牌子
买他们不同的型号。
你干净表情很奇怪。
你是不是又要吐槽我。
不是我好想听你吐槽。
他有个吐槽的
我有吐槽的
谁我忘了
他吐槽过萨洛蒙说。
你如果要滑的话
那是因为
当时去欧洲徒步的时候。
我自己没买
我一直都在萨洛蒙家。
找不到合适我脚型的鞋子。
我每次都是
这么流行的东西
我怎么能不拥有
每次都是
今天我一定要在这个店里。
买到一双
好几次去店里
然后试完
我觉得不是很合适。
但他们家后来
也出了适合宽缺的。
宽缺的
你很方放你的脚
也没有很宽
但我不喜欢那种
赞特蒙的鞋很窄
不太适合亚洲的角色。
挂过品牌
他现在也有宽的
我觉得不能用宽窄。
这个事儿再吐槽
萨洛蒙了
但我一直没买过
当时是去欧洲徒步的时候。
因为有好几个
住在欧洲当地的老外。
还有国人
所以他们好多买了萨洛蒙。
然后路上就一直在滑。
说你穿的什么鞋
为什么你不滑
对
就那期节目
萨洛蒙给我留下了。
深刻的印象
就那期节目播出之后。
好多人跑去
Ultra下班
我觉得都是你带动的。
因为这个牌子没人推。
国内就是
尤其前几年吧？
知道的人少
然后就是好多人
吐槽萨洛蒙
哎呀？
现在也没人推
Ultra是三部在做吗？
不是不是
不是三部在做
不知道谁在做
有一
但是就是说
不知道谁在做市场。
但是呢？
确实是这个牌子比较低调。
但东西真挺好的
我走挺多长线
穿他们家产品特别好。
然后上次去羽绷徒步。
我们还有过河嘛？
其实那个
打石的石头上是特别滑的。
然后我朋友
我那个一起走的队员。
有穿那个
LOA的
就滑得不行
然后我那双
就真的挺稳的
然后大家都觉得说。
哎 这鞋子真不错。
就这两个牌子我很喜欢。
然后
后卡是因为
我觉得它相对好看一点。
相对时髦一点
但是依旧还是有很多。
值得吐槽的
比方说
我觉得
奥川也有值得吐槽的呀？
他们家就是海外款比国内的选择。
要多一些
然后价格也更便宜。
就这点我觉得
那你国内运营
是不是能实施劲
其次就是
我不知道为什么？
就是不至于这两个牌子。
我在买
涂鞋的时候遇到了一个困扰。
就是
这一个型号的鞋
它大概就是一个设计师。
做的吧？
那为什么一到男款女款的。
颜色设计的时候
就感觉就是
一个就突然就特别拉垮了。
我经常想选的颜色都是男款。
然后没有我的尺码。
然后有我的尺码的女鞋。
颜色巨难看
就为什么一定要出什么？
粉啊什么？
就是这种
这个还是就是说
就有很多刻板印象。
我觉得是
就是审美的刻板印象。
就是还有一个就是说。
这个审美是
照顾的是
原来的用户
没有照顾到这个
东亚的用户
东亚的这个审美
跟欧美的审美
就是还是完全不一样的。
对
所以这个颜色
特别值得吐槽
也好多产品都是男款。
比女款好看
在这里面有一个行业的壁柄。
就我们之前
包括我们服务国的客户。
参与过的客户
大家在做产品开发的时候。
会受制于一个事
就是我们
其实开发的时候
设计师会设计很多。
基于前期调研的产品。
比如说他们的人
有可能来到东亚
做了我们东亚
很好的这个配色
然后但是他们有一个。
流程就是要上定货会。
因为他们可能
对就中端的买手也好。
还是说经销商也好。
就来定货
但是经销商和买手。
定货的原则基本上是。
基于过往的历史数据。
没错
那他还是就是刚刚。
谢老板说的
他还是会迎合
原本的这个客户
以及以前是没的选。
才选那些臭东西
对
但是这个就导致
特别伤设计师的心。
很多设计师产品出来了。
最后永远都选不上。
我
中国国内其实有
好多很牛的设计师。
我给你举一个例子。
因为我认识中桥
他们那边的设计师。
就是中国桥单
中桥设计师
你咱们印象中
说哎呀他们可能是。
更大众一点对不对。
设计师其实设计能力。
非常强
审美非常高
不是说普通的高
人能做到那个设计师。
但是实际上
这个每年出来的产品。
还就是那样
我说他为啥不能变。
他说定货贵
我刚刚他一顿设计。
到这定货贵光光
全国打费了
毫不是毛读了劲
我干了两个
我认为比较好的东西。
结果卖的又一般
你说怎么办
他就是比
就是这种情况
他为了照顾原因
他的销售渠道
比如说是很固定的。
比如说你像
澳门或者什么？
他的销售渠道
原来就是那些比较多。
中小也是一样
他销售渠道
他就是原来的销售渠道。
还是做那些产品
但如果你要
变化太大的话
他们就不买了
但是呢？
如果是换成
现在的新媒体渠道。
或者说
电商渠道呢？
可能就是另外一个情况。
但是这个变化
谁也不敢做呀？
你一个设计师
你敢做这些策吗？
你不想要工作了吗？
但是怎么对
比较好的品牌
是非常强势的以前。
比如说像
这样的品牌
由于品牌的话语权。
更高
所以他每年会配
15%到30%
他们总不认为的趋势款。
就是硬配
是错款
不是就是硬配
配货
我说对经销商来说。
就我的是错款
对对对
就跟你买爱马仕一样。
你不接受
那对不起
你拿不到我其他的货。
那如果这样的话
他整个市场的趋势。
才能会被扭转过来。
这也是
我们的一个
行业痛点嘛？
对
好
先说完了
我先为啥看
我笑啊？
其实笑并不是说
嘲笑你
就是
因为我赞同你
因为我觉得
后卡加的鞋呢？
有一款
我不是说随我
有一款叫奥刹
奥刹那些
应该是得先上定是吧？
我不知道
我没买过这个
奥刹那些
好像不是线下店有卖的。
他那个鞋
那是个徒步鞋
徒步鞋
但是他也很多
潮人穿
奥刹
你可以搜一下
那个鞋有很多
款的配色
连名款的配色
那就
那是一个地的
我跟你说
老妹绝对是符合
你的审美啊？
等不了一遍
对
但是有点贵
你只能在
你不在线下学校买。
你怎么叫
发售还是怎么着
我不知道那怎么个说法。
就是你抽签
或者排队
但是你可以在
其他学校上去买
这东西
各种各样的配色
合作款是很好的
但是其他的呢？
比如说
我觉得他家那个
还有一个叫奥刹
是吧？
就底太软了
就不一定适合这个。
后卡的哪个信号
你说底太软了
我刚才
就是后卡那个
卡哈
对对对
那个穿的人挺多
挺多
但是他不太适合徒步。
我认为
那卡哈不太适合徒步。
但是奥刹很适合这个。
你说的是这个吧？
有好多合作款
他有好多颜色
他不止这个颜色
这个我买过一个
这个我买过一个懒色。
但就是常规款
这个我买的
还是个高帮
你买高帮是吧？
我也有一个这个鞋。
蓝色的
他这有很多什么？
我才800块买的。
你多少钱买的
我花4000块
对
我那天当时就是
就那一双了
然后在海外
打指挪的一个买手电。
我当时就说
是不是给我的鞋
我必须得买
高帮的
然后那个
那太贵了
那个贵人的我的知信腾。
但是为了那个颜值。
是好看
对
而且他他合作款
有很多颜色
有特别的
而且这个鞋呢？
整体的鞋面看起来。
比较秀气
没有那么愣
我觉得如果女儿喜欢的话。
如果要重装
这个可能还是比较适合你们。
嗯
是是是
这个
然后呢？
还有一个是
还有一个我最近比较喜欢的。
就是那个
拉斯帕蒂瓦那个TX5。
嗯
那个鞋我也觉得好。
那个鞋我是觉得
原来都吐槽这鞋窄吗？
新版是宽了还是怎么着。
他应该也是
现在是有那个
同一款有宽靴的设计。
和常规款的设计
他有挺多鞋子
现在是这样
他说我现在穿了
一个新的这个TX5。
我觉得无敌了
拉斯帕蒂瓦的配色。
一直还是非常经典的。
我觉得作为意大利鞋。
因为意大利的衣服配色。
总是让人非常的震惊。
就包括我们最近看了。
一个新的品牌
是C打头的一个
一个高海拔灯的品牌。
哇 那叫一个壮色。
我觉得他在东北
可能会非常受伤
没有说东北不好的意思是说。
很热烈
明白了
更快放一点
对对对
然后但是他的那个。
就拉斯帕蒂瓦的配色。
虽然有一些
以前包括他们的衣服。
有一些比较亮的
但是他的配色
我觉得还是非常的。
有点偏北欧一些
就是还是比较内敛的。
然后鞋子也是
他们
谢老板新说的这个型号。
我还真没有了解过。
TX5
大家可以回头看看。
我只知道他们最近的。
市场动作非常的多。
就感觉到他们
想认认真正做中国市场了。
原来基本上就是属于跟。
那个
Ultra
他们是一个感觉
吊儿当当的
吊儿当当
就是说
我也不充卖
我一年就进这些货。
我卖完了
我也不想做太大
我做太大做太好的话呢？
我怕这个人
自己拿回去做
我觉得有这样的心态。
但是
我不知道现在可能就是开始。
不过玩一玩未来穿。
因为现在在三夫旗下了。
我觉得三夫还是相对。
会比较积极一些
明白了
我觉得这个还挺好的。
这个而且我那款是。
有限量款
不是限量款
但是我那款是军绿色。
上面有点小梅红
小梅红小边
那应该很好看
小小的比例很小
但是在点綴了
老板烧得很
我发现
那鞋我也推荐两个。
一个是非常知名的。
就是凯勒什的大破王。
那我同时也吐槽一下。
我个人是觉得
这鞋真的很丑
但它很好穿
但是它很好穿
它很好穿
就为什么设计师
一定要把它设计成。
一个变形金刚的感觉呢？
真的不好看
但是功能真的很好。
就在耐磨上
而且可怕的是
在越野跑赛道上
我觉得它的渗透率。
非常高
然后另外一款很小众。
是今年去北欧的时候。
火柴棍有一款鞋
我之前从来没觉得说。
火柴棍的鞋这么优秀。
叫Horizon。
也是它的lim系列。
好轻
我以前穿中邦的登山鞋。
总是觉得脚排不舒服。
但这一款是
非常舒服也非常轻。
它有一个绿色的配色。
哇好美
我们当时去的时候。
跟几个博主一起
他们一进门就说
这个鞋好美
后来他们很多款没进中国。
但这款进中国了
但我选的是一个米色的。
我觉得真的是
我近年来穿过的
登山鞋里面最好穿的一双。
你说
看不到呢怎么感觉。
这个他们也是让
他们就是
他们或少
他们刚进中国一年嘛？
所以才逐渐在开店。
然后我们还参与了。
一部分他们的营销。
但是就是
刚进中国
一个是店
也不多
全国就28家店
但基本上都是一线商场。
另外一个就是
营销
我觉得目前还属于。
相对比较低调的状态。
明白明白
但是这个鞋子
因为他们家大家知道。
什么LIM系列的。
冲锋衣系列什么的。
就很厉害
雪芙更厉害
但是鞋子
从来不是他们
最被提及的品类
但我这次觉得
还是挺有惊喜的
前两天还有人
在微博上给我留言。
我之前推荐过
他们家一个毛线帽。
历时一年多
那个人说我终于买到了。
对 就是
他好像还是去
不知道是哪个
买到
他说他去了好多次。
他们的专卖店
都没有这块
米娅真的是带货房。
因为我们群里面
有一个叫喜航的人。
就因为你买了
他去找了好多的店。
最后在成都
太古礼店买到了
就那款帽子
其实我有那个帽子。
我也不知道
那个帽子真的很好。
魅力在这
你看我很在意帽子。
朋友们
米娅严选
我推的帽子
他都可以考虑
别的不一定
是的
那我们讲完鞋
现在讲第三个大类。
就是背包
这个
你们是不是都很有发言。
尤其是米娅
买了好多包
对 但是我没买那些。
最有名的那两个牌子。
格里高利和小英
格里高利买过一个。
但我还是海桃买
他们家贼一边远的产品。
估计都没人买
然后这两个
我一直不想买
就是不好看
我真的觉得不好看。
我真的买不下手
那你还没被洗一洗的。
差不多
还有一些坚持
还可以坚持
再洗几两件试试
对
但是玩重装玩的少。
我后边是真的玩重装。
你就是要背那么多东西。
你可能就是算了
舒服最重要
能背的都最重要
也就开始买了
这两个牌子怎么说呢？
我有可能算是吐槽吧？
我就是每次都想买。
但是能不能咱就把。
这个颜色各方面
做的稍微好看点
那我就反吐槽你一下。
那你说的是
那个小英格里高利是吧？
对
我想
你觉得包在这个
衣服里面
你觉得它算是
这个主角还是配角。
我觉得它在我
头部的这个场景
它是
主角
它是主角是吧？
那衣服算什么？
你把衣服放哪儿了。
衣服和它是
品级的
它不是个配件对我来说。
因为它体积很大
它拍照的时候
站的体积很大
那你觉得它
是这么个意思是吧？
对
所以你看我
你知道我第一个买的。
图包是什么？
我第一个买的图包。
是潘山鼠的一个包。
就是为了好看
它也有一定的背负。
但是也就是25声的。
所以它就是
其实有一个腰带
你说这个背
它没什么设计
那我有个
关键点
就是这些包在后面。
你进上拍照的时候。
拍的都是背影啊？
是吗？
对呀？
OK
我可不给你拍图了。
这次我了
OK 我直接说了。
我觉得包是配件
或者说包在整个山大里边。
它是个配角
配角也很重要
你叫点睛之笔
经常都是配角
我说话点
为什么我们爱马师。
它不就是个配角
那个手带
摄制品的手带
这个跟背包还不一样。
因为背包大部分
还在身后的
我认为啊？
我们拍照的时候
可能正面45度
正面就是侧面
这个比较多
背面其实
虽然说它比例
也不是很小
但是它并不是
最主要的角度之后。
所以你觉得美观
我觉得它不能抢
它可以是搭配
但它不能抢
就是搭不上呀？
太丑
它这个
它就是
它比较颜色
我认为它不抢
它就好了
比如说你是一个
黑色的一个
或者说
主要还是你的衣服。
它是一个小配件
多一个结构
然后你就不用
它太鲜艳
它如果真的颜色鲜艳。
除非能给你鞋
或者帽子能搭上
那是挺好的
它如果搭不上
你还不如说
那就让它别太粗粗。
这是我的感觉
它就是
比方说
就是同样是黑色的包。
都可以设计的空间。
所以你看男性的女性。
有一个很大的区别。
就是
我也不知道是不是男性女性。
至少你们俩就是
就是男性也没事
就是对于
设计关注的
颗粒度是不太一样的。
而且我
接触到的大多数女性。
其实对于背包
还是认为
它是一个主角
对
它还是很大一块的。
我到现在
唯一我觉得大的包。
我那个是
65升的一个大背包。
我买下来
我觉得我很满意
那样滑又舒服
又长得好看
主要是因为它长得好看。
我买
但后来发现真舒服。
是一个瑞士的牌子。
他们家是做
他们家是做滑雪的。
叫Expand
巨小众
然后我上次
那是小众
我上次背那个包
Xpack
是Xpack吗？
EXPED
不知道
没听过
对
我上次背这个去的时候。
那个忍者狗
咱们
我跟老柴都认识的一个。
出外播出
说你怎么有这个包。
我早就想买
能不能借我试一试。
另外一个女孩
有一个女博主
她这包太好看了
立刻在那儿买
她说你在哪儿买的。
我说香港代购
她说我在咸鱼上找到。
我说你买吧？
这包值得买
又清凉滑
又能装
然后真的很好看
是吧？
真的很好看
确实是
还挺多
好看的包
她也得逃
就得研究
大部分的包
其实我看到的
就还是黑色
然后比如说
这种棕色
那种蓝色
就是那种欧洲蓝
欧洲人最愿喜欢那种蓝。
然后包括橙色
降红色
然后还有一些就是。
就大部分都这颜色。
反正就是咱们正常东亚人。
喜欢的颜色其实是没有的。
为什么我说
凯勒什就在配色上比较好。
就凯勒什他有些这种。
比较有意思的
就女性能喜欢的包。
比如说有些白包
上面有点小粉的点缀。
或者有些这种
整个包都是紫色的。
我觉得虽然也是
这个体系里边
但是还是做了点
我认为是做了点变化。
这是我
我觉得我能接受
我那个包是个黑色的。
回头我想发给
些老板看一看
真的很好看
那为啥黑色你觉得。
你觉得是造型
不是颜色是吧？
对 就是你得
你这个包
它得有点美感
那车不都黑色
怎么你就说
保时捷为啥好看
那它就是得
你得有些设计
你就算是外挂的挂点。
你也可以把它做好看。
就像你觉得
有些拼色
有些亮色去装饰
我觉得很重要
我没法给你形容
它多好看
我给你发照片
你给我发照片
那我收我的了
既然你说的
女性喜欢的包
那我必须得说
男性喜欢的包
神秘农场
你就是个神农喜欢。
这个包其实说实话。
我先说槽点
这个包太重了
对 又重了
而且那个后背
有比较热
因为它那个材料
就那样
而且这个包
确实是一个
年头很多的包
但是你就有些男的。
定位就是户外包
对不对
他以前是军队和
卡列装
对 列装了
或者是说这个不对用的。
但是呢？
它就是有些像我们这种的。
你说它是军迷
还不是
但是就对这种
比较硬朗的
这种军事方式的东西。
你就特别喜欢吃迷。
我买过它家一个
七十一生的
它那个都挺产的
七十一生的一个冰川。
大包
叫木宗色
也是拼色
但是那个木是木宗色。
当时我忘了花多少钱了。
只能买到二手的
而且是个大价钱
在韩国
逃的那么一个东西。
橙色还不错
有的那个造的也不行。
但是那个
我这还不错的
逃的那个包
我非常喜欢
爱到头儿的
我说舍不得
舍不得借
舍不得足的这种的。
你知道吗？
然后还有一个是
我有它家三款包
还有它都是宗色
还有一个是裤里的。
二十生的裤里的
二十生的裤里
是戴背附系统的
那个
然后裤里那个包
也挺出名的
还有一个叫粗贝
粗贝那个包
更没法平时粗悟悲了。
没想到粗悟悲
那个只能做一通行包。
就是它家的包
它就是
我觉得是好看
男性会觉得好看
女性可能会觉得
就是金鸟的感觉
神秘农场有款吧？
我还挺想买的
当时一直没买
就是有点贵
我没下得去手
Redix
是个白色的款
对对对
一个大
应该是这个
Redix吗？
对
应该是不是Redix。
它没写
我随便搜了个那个小公主笔记。
它没写这些
这个呢？
就是属于
就不像它家包的
不是它家的传统室妹。
对对对
在我们的眼里
就是属于它虽然挺好。
但是呢？
它就
不是他们的性格
不纯
血
也不是纯血
在级的
变了
你变了
你妥协市场了
是Redix
是是是
对
但是神农
去年被
前年
主流的线嘛？
对
你们爱好者
会有一些什么样的影响吗？
没有影响
其实
它不是我们
我们其实也没有那么爱它。
或者说
我们是爱它
但是不是那种说
狂热那种
它还是
它还是个包
但是不过这种风格呢？
其实在户外背包里面。
属于兑份
但是你说
如果说
其他的包呢？
我是觉得
有有几款
我这女孩会比较喜欢的。
听听
哈哈哈
怀疑我
对
露出了挑战的
那你这样
你有一款包
我觉得我很喜欢
叫HMG
HMG
你可以搜一下
这个呢？
他们家那是白色的背。
他们
那个超轻的那个
超轻的
一个是又轻
一个是颜色又白
挺多人背
很多人背
它这个比较潮
而且价格也挺贵
对
有一定的这种
潮流感
但是呢？
它家这个包就是爱脏。
好神奇
在我们录制的此刻。
它两天前
刚刚入住小红书
所以没买
这个是因为我觉得它这个。
我觉得它这个
对收纳的要求还挺高的。
就是它是个长筒的一个造型。
它还有小包
对
它有小包
它侧面就是这种
没有什么？
就我喜欢是那个
有那个外挂点
和那个一些袋什么的。
我能弄衣服
但是没买
就是因为我觉得
这个我可能装不好。
我倒是可能不稳
我买了一个小包
差不多17升
怎么个小包
但是它这个包
就像你说的一样
它很难装
它需要你自己
有很好的收纳系统。
这么整理的
习惯
好的习惯
对这个是很
但是我认为女孩
可能背这种包呢？
好看的
好看
还有别的颜色
挺好看
一个是很简约
还有呢？
它就敢收纳
但我就不能说了
除非那种
我还真的有
但我真的不能给你再说了。
效果好看
这个包确实不错
挺多人背
而且它颜色是那种白色。
白色呢？
我就是
因为咱们图 app 图包里边。
很少有出现这种颜色。
你放它就容易脏了。
但是过去两年
白色的各种高度好火。
出了好多
你觉得是因为什么？
是因为一个火了
其他家就都出了
是这个原因吗？
不知道
我觉得是不是女性用户。
或者是这种
对颜值有需求的用户。
因为它这个白颜色。
肯定是不适合
在户外去搞的
对
我觉得是前面
咪雅提到过一句话。
非常非常经典
她说我就去个京郊。
我也不需要直升级救援。
是
为什么要背那种颜色。
或穿那种颜色的衣服。
我觉得逐渐有
越来越多的人
发现了这一点
白色的包是我们去年。
带两个外国的
同行去调颜的时候。
走进施宗鸟
施宗鸟有一款
走进凯勒士
凯勒士有一款
好像看山鼠也有
北面也有
对就是
偏有点像那个
粗本那种
对对对
加加一个
每家都有
我觉得有一个
就它
我就单纯说
这个产品
对我的感
白色的包
背包对我的感觉
我也不知道
还为什么流行
它有非常强烈的冲突感。
就是白
它不应该出现在户外。
户外不是
你得耐脏吗？
但是我不
我就要买个白
这就好比有些人
就是穿白色
就显得贵
因为我不从事体力劳动。
我不怕衣服脏
我白衣服弄脏了
我很轻松
我可能去干洗
我不需要担心
它洗不干净
就白这个颜色
本身背后
背后有非常多
社会学的意义
因为我天呐
我才发现这种感觉。
是的
就是
我不会脏的
我也不怕脏
我不怕脏
因为不是要我洗
我的生活习惯
我不需要
我不会出那么多汗。
而且我
我当然在那包上没洗。
底下都弄得脏了
没洗
然后我甚至觉得
可能洗不干净的
对对
所以我觉得
白色出现在户外
它就是有张力
这是一个很深的观察。
难的
反正是我肯少看到。
他们去背这种
白包
李珊卫过
收音机背
是的
我们跟他们那边比。
我觉得他那是赞柱。
他那是背面的赞柱。
另一个字也背
对
这个就是赞柱了
但收音机的确是
他有好多包
但是他最喜欢背的。
我看就是那个白色。
好看
就是真的好看
是的
对
OK
那我们
最后两个
先来聊聊
放在一起聊吧？
就睡眠系统
和小装备类的
你们有什么推荐
和吐槽的
这个我就不专业了。
我觉得这个
可以让细老板好好讲。
那小装备你不是
有帽子吗？
睡眠系统的话
我就去年
今年刚入的那个
西兔三米
卡住了
不好意思
西兔三米的东西
挺好的
我去年10月份
因为是
因为是老差强力
给我安利的
我们俩去年
参加活动
在川期徒步的时候。
米亚塔在帐篷里面。
他一个人一个帐篷。
然后那天晚上狠了。
他一直说
老差没有花钱的
不是
就是我觉得
STS的帐篷
真的很顶
但确实
要吐槽的话
就是价格确实有点高。
没有花钱
我们那帐篷
当时不需要咱俩自己打。
到了打好了
咱都不需要
体验那些麻烦的过程。
对
而且STS
好处是
它会有些女性的板。
是的
太专业了
这是去年才出的
但是你吐槽吗？
可以吐槽
我先吐槽
我先把它这个
夸好
你先打好底
我先把它打好底
然后你再
我先拉上去
好吧？
你再拉下来
小瑕疵
就是这种
因为大部分的
睡袋这种东西
包括帐篷
它都是通感
是
它简单
背货少
所以它这个睡袋
做的这种通感
包括气垫也是
它就是做通感
对
但是实际上女性
和男性
它的身材是一不一样的。
所以它为了
贴合度更好
保暖性更强
它有些品牌
就比较
说实话比较高的品牌。
或者是比较有
有实力的品牌
就是我做了
我能卖出去
它才敢做这种
女性
就是说适合女性
专属的
这个很重要
因为你
如果那个地方
你控制它
可能就没有那么保暖。
对
我觉得STS
还是很厉害的
是因为它压货
和那个压货
对
我听戏老板那么说完。
我突然有点理解了。
就是它因为它
我之前看睡袋的时候。
我看它有女性款
就同样的充容量
同样的
那个舒适温度
女性款会贵一点
我当时说
怎么着
还得给你交
那个性别税
但是其实这么一想。
它确实
它那个可能背货就少。
它这个生产的成本。
自然就高了
以及它在结构上
是比男性要更复杂。
它当时考虑到说
女性有一些部位会。
宽一点
以及更怕凉
所以它的充容量
多少都不一样
以及我当时觉得
特别感动的是
他们做了大量的调研。
说女性在户外
更容易侧我
而男性更容易仰臥。
所以它在这个结构上。
也做了一些调整
所以它成本就是高。
对
那我当时没
没盖到这点
我就后来买了个通用板。
对不起
但通用板会有点大吗？
因为它是澳洲的那个板。
就是它有那个不同的size。
我什么睡袋
我用的都挺大
咱就是矮
对
但是它那个
其实这种细节
你要是在意就在意。
你不在意也OK
比如我就买通用板。
这也没什么问题
对
你说能有多大的差别。
就还好
但有人可能愿意做。
我觉得这个还是值得加讲的。
但是肯定有好处
但是就有一个
点缀的强调
就说
好
比如说这个女性板。
和这个通用板
它可能只提升了
3%的优势
对
但价格
提升了20%
对
但是这个就是
有的人愿意去换
但是这个确实是
3%的提升
要花的代价
可能就不是3%的代价了。
对
因为它不是从30%。
往上提3%
它是从90%往上提3%。
它可能就是很难
它也难
这个就是不是说
提它解释
它也难
它也不是说
我就提升3%
这突然是有
广告指数吗？
没有广告指数
但是就是我
这个里边有些人
他就会觉得说
你凭什么？
就
但是如果大家
就是没有那么的需要。
3%
就买那个通板
就买通板
反正我买通板
我觉得挺好的
我得说
我跟STS是有这个。
利益相关性的
但是我就在这儿
不说话了
因为它是我的客户。
但是我自己使用完。
我觉得他们家产品。
真的是各项产品
都非常的顶
因为跟他们
全球总部沟通完
就是一个
完全nerd的公司。
每个人都是
工程师思维
能看出来
能从他们的影像上。
看出来
是呆呆的
就是他们的
你看他们那个网店。
这是兔子
再看他们那个公众号。
呆呆的
就是他们可能就是。
就是有时候吧？
我能理解
对不起
澳洲村里来的
没有提示
这次的意思
有时候吧？
他可能会
产品为主的人
就是他就没有那么？
在意这个
传播的东西
我觉得
而且就像谢老板说的。
我要但凡
是一个认真做生意的人。
我不会开那么多SKU的。
他们家SKU
实在多到疯掉了
对
那家伙都太恐怖了。
是的
这有护房的压力呢？
对
沉迷于开各种
这样的小东西
哇
在这个品牌真的
太奇怪了
快来说说
其他的那个小方位。
这来到谢老板的
硕士区
硕士区是吧？
然后再说帐篷吧？
帐篷
帐篷也算顺位系统。
快给我推荐
还有一个
咱不能只说
这个国外的
那个黑冰的也不错。
黑冰的最近不是
睡袋
我去县家摸过
是挺好的
挺舒服的
对 县家比较高
我觉得你要说
他做得多精一化
但是他已经不一定做得一化。
但是呢？
这个属于我认为
大家能摸得着的品质感的。
县家比较高的
这个麦也比较不错。
这是他
还有一个小
更小众的
叫冰宴
我知道
冰宴
他就
做方了
他是能定制吗？
应该能定制吧？
他就做方了
做方的意思有属于。
他这麽多就更低了。
但是他家东西确实。
硬核的玩家好多都不知道。
对 硬核的玩家会知道。
你看 你就把有的人会知道。
我不是硬核
就他家知道
冰宴那两个居然
就是冰宴
宴火的宴
你属于他们家吗？
我经常在展会看到他们家。
就是也是跟那个
而且他们差不多
人比较
简单
失忆了两秒
他不是那种人
他也是就是做产品。
产品的人
所以他们家不光睡眠。
还有其他产品
就是羽绒的东西
就羽绒东西
其实并不复杂
挺好
就喜欢这种产品
思维的人
对 然后还有
帐篷吧？
帐篷我最近
最近用的两款
一个是冷衫
通过底冷衫
这个基本上就是
大家都知道
用了好多年了
价格有便宜
标准版的冷衫
你才400多块钱。
都不到500块钱。
那就是产品非常高了。
然后呢？
但是它重
当然它还有一款是。
超级款的
差不多
一千多是不是
可能一千左右
一千左右
这个你现在
我们要去一半玩
那个整个这个冷衫的。
那个颜色
有好多比如10个里边。
能用32他们家这样。
产品比较高
还有一款呢？
是我最近才
收到的一个账
是国内的
大家是DEC的高。
然后呢？
多奈福的这种扣
反正总之品质比较不错。
叫
叫扎曼
没听过
没听过啊？
是一个很小的论选。
刚开始做
但是东西其实还不错。
这个我觉得
我最近用了
他家两款帐篷
我过两天会有一个视频。
大家可以去
谢老板的
户外vlog
去看看
不去
但是这个呢？
就我觉得是
如果说
两个里边最推荐哪个。
我觉得
冷衫的那个
UOL
还有一个
他家有一个
失败骨骼的
叫冷衫的风力
叫N39
这两款都是
我觉得新鲜比非常高的。
如果
就是价格也比较合适。
重量也比较轻
我觉得是挺好的
UOL我看好多人玩。
他就是用不多
大量人在
对
消费
对我出去玩的时候。
也有就是那个
一起走的队友推荐说。
这特好
你算是你买一个玩。
特好
感受那种价格合适的。
对对对
谢老板怎么看自由之魂。
没什么事
也可以不说
没事
可以不说什么？
保留意见
怎么说呢？
这个就是我
到他身上了
我就又犯起了
那个凯勒什那个毛病了。
你知道我那感觉吗？
我就又站在一种
那种角度
我说他
为什么要卖这么贵。
东西还是挺好的
东西挺好的
就是会觉得
贵
我觉得帐篷产业
现在整个在
什么阶段呢？
我有一天去
e-spo去那个。
他们那个总经理的办公室。
他收到了一个
我忘了是哪个
自由之魂吗？
不是
是一个价格更低的品牌。
但他们那个
他们发来了一个
概念版的帐篷
每一个配件用到的。
都是最顶配的
配件
然后面料也是
最贵的
他用大力码的那个面料。
我说
哇这么下本
就那个帐篷
我们亲手搭起来之后。
觉得哇
真是好
只是概念款
只是报价款
因为他们不会
批量生产
也就是
帐篷现在我们国内的。
生产工艺其实
可以达到
一级水平
但是就还是存在
那个国际品牌
和国内品牌的问题。
如果这个牌子
把这一款推出之后。
他哪怕卖的是国际品牌的。
二分之一
或者三分之一的价格。
大家可能不认
你说我现在有个
什么感觉吗？
你比如说
像自由之魂
也是这种面料
也是DAC的这个帐篷。
然后呢？
沙娜也是
还有很多别的品牌。
也用DAC的仗格。
包括这个
帐篷的造型
其实也都差不多
但是自由之魂
就会比他们都贵
很多
就是我是觉得你
人家你的帐篷造型。
也都大杀不杀
咱都是这个
这个就是什么？
十字交叉也好
或者是双交叉
这都差不多
我就会觉得说
他们可以做到这样。
那你为什么？
比他们贵这么多呢？
那你贵这么多
总要有个原因
就是这个意思
你知道吗？
就是我觉得贵
的原因
那不说呢？
我的造型
帐篷的研发
花了很多钱
大家不都是
差不多的造型吗？
我之所以问
谢老板这个问题
是因为
谢老板在我们圈内。
是非常有名的
录影装备专家
所以
帐篷你肯定研究的。
非常多
所以我就问你
对于这个品牌的看法。
我跟他们
帐篷不熟
他们帐篷不熟
可不能都瞎说
我只是觉得价格
可能是不是
可以
或者他也是
品牌的定位的问题。
他就是
想服务这样
可能不那么在意
价格的
不在意价格
但是有些细节
做的比较顶
对
他可能天然的
再筛选一些用户
我觉得就是
还有一个好办法
就像你女孩似的
就我们男的
也得学学你们
两个帐篷买回来
看一下
摸一下
对不对
这个贴了
我做的品牌
上次喝在第一戏
我们退货率
实在太高了
是吧？
这个确实是
服装的确实是这样。
因为他就是
还是得多看
多摸
还有或者是
不这么买一个
还有个好办法
比如说
现下去看
咱一起出去玩吗？
你带一个
我带一个
看别人了
来回摸
然后看
包括你的使用感受。
这个就更加的直接。
是的
然后再去消费
奇怪男的
我们在
炸一些
谢老板的干货
其他装备
其实一直被大家
忽略的一个
我觉得中国的
头灯线是不是
已经做到世界顶级了。
那个牌叫什么？
耐特克
对
你看王一波
用的也是这个
我用的也是
王一波头款
王一波还用黑钻
我当时买
我当时买的时候
是因为他很轻
然后我买回来
发现
这是一个国产品牌。
很意外
价格也不高
国内的这些牌子
都很厉害了
你说
国外的牌子
也好
国内很多牌子
也很厉害
咱不能说
他好像在欧美卖的。
也很好是不是
他东西现在比较高。
东西又好
你说那为什么不卖呢？
对
我们在欧洲看到的。
还是黑钻居多
因为毕竟他就是老牌子。
老牌子
对
但是
带电的东西
我们中国的真的
一点也不输他们的。
我们使用感受
就这次去那个北欧。
我们在帐篷里面
由于
中国队
有一个帐篷
他们有大概
二十盏头灯
所以他们被牌队
来借头灯
他们拿的特别多
就很多那个
国外的大使们
都在观摩说
今天还说这么好的东西。
对
在哪儿买的各种各样的灯。
是
很好
但是呢？
如果可以的话
还是我那个
点就是
能不能多给出点颜色。
头灯
你倒是
挑上颜色了
我头灯
怎么不能挑颜色呢？
他是主角
还是配角
他在脸这
他是脸这
他在头上
你照片
我觉得最重要的
还是跟脸相关的
跟脸近的
我觉得这个颜色
还是比较重要
那你刚才说
帽子不重要
帽子也重要
真好笑
帽子重要
但是我说的第一次。
是帽子
所谓遮阳的功能
在我们这儿不重要。
你看我都这样说的了。
你看我都这样说
所以我觉得
帽子这样
但是帽子造型的功能。
比较重要
我这么认为的
他缺帅着我
高正
所以是希望
头灯出更多的颜色。
没错
我给你举个例子
有很多牌子出
摩戴尔就是
都挺好看的
但是摩戴尔
跟耐德克尔
质量比
性能比还是差一些。
然后还有就是
比如说我戴个
什么样子帽子
或者说穿什么样子衣服。
比如说穿一个
银光绿的一个冲锋衣。
那我这个
如果能戴一个
银光绿的这么一个。
头灯
是不是还挺好看
小面也不大
固定一下
没想到
没想到这个需求
我没想到
戴尔王衣博
你看
他现在又变成
另外一个
你刚才怎么说的
你
现在你又说不重要了。
笑死
头灯我觉得是挺好。
这个我认为
它是比较
就是它能搭配
又有水源功能
而且它是个
叫强制装备
对
你要出去突破
你今天是
一天还是两天
你怎么样
你必须得戴上
你保不齐
你万一你出来玩的呢？
对吧？
你保不齐有什么问题。
对对对
走得慢了
之类的
那必须得戴上
所以这个手装的
戴的个儿是挺好的。
然后那个
黑钻戴上
黑钻的贵
那黑钻是好
现在那个
我推荐啊？
我推荐一个什么的。
我就不推荐哪款
但是买头灯
一定要买那种
能可以装AA电池的。
加上充电电池的
就是你保底
你必须要能装AA电池。
对
就会保险很多
明白
因为有些地方
你的充电电池没电了。
是
你可以随时能买
因为这个东西
很好过去
那个线
那个是那个镇
非洲
非洲对吧？
都能买到
能买到同样东西
你按上去就能使
你不至于说这个事你瞎了。
这个就是
我觉得这个是一个。
保命的东西
保命东西
建一样的双东立法。
好
这个太重要了
当然了
还有什么？
还有
再问一个非常重要的。
因为经常有人在群里问。
我们就是登山帐
你俩有推荐的品牌吗？
我
Black Diamond。
我就直接上了一个折叠的。
那个最新的那个帐。
两个帐加起来的
对
预算充足的可以跟证明。
而且
我觉得挺耐用的
之前买了
他不是探鞋围说
很容易断什么？
用三四年了
挺好的
没那么夸张
我觉得
对
你正常使用
他没那么脆
谢老板有推荐的章吗？
就是
探鞋围是什么呢？
它可能在这种
寒冷环境下
包括有的时候
跌倒了
可能就断了
多冷
零下30度之类的吗？
二三十度
但是不常见的了
就是挺常见的
低温情况了
那它在低温情况下。
它就容易断
就是这个
但是你确实是没断。
没断是
幸存者偏差
你也不能那么说
就是它最重要的一个。
就跟交换交通事故是一样的。
别让你遇上
你别有一次
有一次
你就会比较难受
但是还好
有什么有些环境
你就算没有登山杖。
也能走
这是我
但是我觉得登山杖。
就是说
探鞋围的也可以
但是旅的呢？
因为有些
很好的登山杖
他能也能做到
对对
旅的也挺清的
对对对
登山杖
我有好多
什么样都有
我最近
我比较喜欢的
但是他说便宜的时候贵的。
都来一点吧？
都来点是吧？
都来一点的话
我觉得
如果说徒步的话
你像木高迪
你像弩克
他们都有这种
一百多块钱一套
一百多块钱一根的。
其实已经很成熟了对吧？
对
反正性价比挺高的。
就是木高迪 弩克这种的。
你就不用考虑杂牌了。
他俩之外的那种杂牌。
你还不熟
他俩这个东西
就是你觉得比如说。
如果说有可能说
有些产品
可能会有些瑕疵
对吧？
因为他价格太便宜了。
但是呢？
大部分的
没什么问题的
你就使呗
他也使不坏
你比那些
咱们有时候去登山什么的。
他们那个向导租给你那些。
你不如自己买一个。
没错
一百多块
连百多块钱
他能买一顿类似这样。
他很便宜
就这个我觉得就很好了。
就便宜的
贵的呢？
除了你那个
毕地的那个
然后我最近有一个。
我觉得挺好的
但是呢？
我那个杖杆长的
是叫
它其实不是个登山杖。
它是不是登山的牌子。
Halinox你知道吧？
对
Halinox不是出那个。
它有一款登山杖
那为什么长了呢？
它这个是登山杖什么呢？
登山杖是
它不是伸缩的
也就是说是固定长度的。
比如说
我的身高
你买长了是吧？
不买长了
ok ok
我觉得它这个产品设计。
你说都不现场
不是我买长了
但是那个杖呢？
如果不是那个长了。
我老喜欢
长了五公分
是因为好看吗？
因为Halinox。
真的很好看
这韩国品牌
身为非常好
身为非常好看
它就是
我觉得这个
如果再做几年的话。
再这个延续做一些。
我觉得非常好
它是铝的还是
铝合金的
但是呢？
他们家本来就是做杖杆。
DAC的杖杆
做的就非常的出名。
对他们杖可以
所以它那个杖
它那个登山杖本身。
就是个非常好的铝合金。
就是又
铝合金的好处
是当它弯了的时候。
它也不断
它有韧性
有一次我去徒步的时候。
但是那个时候
拿的是BD的那个。
我就看了那个杖杆。
弯到这么个程度
挂又挂回来了
这要是抵得上去碎了。
因为那个时候是特别的。
挂
我看了那个半度了。
基本上就是这样了。
而回来了
我说
没蛇也没坏
挺好
是一个铝合金的
那我就比较放心
要是个炭就基本上蛇了。
蛇无所谓
蛇也没关系
但是呢？
蛇的话呢？
但如果你换来
你一路的这种清松。
那就是没问题
对
是的
然后弹杞登山杖
大家可能还会比较推荐。
like it
我觉得他们家的施战率。
可能跟BD也差不多。
对
然后便宜的呢？
还有万事不决Dekanong。
Dekanong的杖。
口碑也确实还挺好的。
对
所以就是刚
我觉得谢老板的
这个提醒特别对
就是大家
与其买那个
如果是入门
与其买杂牌
就至少咱们买些
这个比较知名的
罗克呀？
木高迪呀？
Dekanong。
反正都不会差到哪去。
对
但是你要好的
那就往BD
like it
或者刚说
比较独特的
然后like it。
有个特点是什么？
因为like it。
主要是越跑
它那个颜色
比较鲜艳一点
所以呢？
有的人的女儿
可能会比较喜欢
有点粉色
亮色这种事
好的
我其实还有好多问题。
但是一转眼
我们都已经快录
到两个小时了
一谈到装备
这个就
接下来还有些问题。
要不我们就用
快问快答的方式
可以
我们
快问
虽然是快很快的
没想到
因为突如其来的问题。
好
我们接下来想想说。
有哪些需求
还没有被真正满足。
因为我们在节目
开始之前
谢老板也跟我聊
比如说光上厕所
这个情况
可能男生跟女生
都不太一样
那你们觉得有哪些场景。
是男性设计
是容易忽略的
你先来
内衣
快吐槽吐槽
内衣真的就是
你不懂
我怎么你不懂
就是
真的就是在凑合
没有
就是
让我觉得太牛逼了。
就是运动内衣
对
运动内衣
你最近不是买了很多吗？
是不乱吗？
对
不乱
那你正常的不乱不行吗？
当然不行了
你这
先说
有的正常女生
有时候日常穿的
她是带钢圈的
对
那不舒服呀？
而且她承托利哥
她不适合你
做高强度的运动
如果来往上
不有很多那种运动。
有很多
我跟你说
她其实就是把
这个
你的这个
胸绑在你身上
你是很难受的
而且
就是我之前还看了一个。
就有人专门去测
那个市场上卖的最好的。
几款运动内衣
它的素干鞋
你看
我外边
对吧？
我没预没
我在外面素干
然后我这衣服
那衣服都顶配
然后里面穿的是个。
那个
运动内衣
湿了以后干不了
你身上一直是湿的。
特别难受
我问个问题
如果不穿会怎么样。
不穿的话
走的时候
第一磨擦
别说女性了
男性的跑越越跑的时候。
她也会磨擦
你跑对
然后第二呢？
就是
如果胸大一点的女生。
她就会晃动
会让你非常不适
明白
然后还有就是出汗。
对 非常累
就是我以前那个
我上学的时候
我同桌是个
比较丰满的女生
她真的是就是
有的时候会把胸
放在桌子上
很累
所以我就说
你无法想象这个事。
有多难受
她很难受
这个一下子说到
因为我们今天社群里面。
有个人说
叫瑞熊的一个女孩子说。
老柴想问问
如何避免运动BRA。
磨胸磨被磨夜下的。
这个还是
刚米亚没提到的一个。
确实你要穿运动BRA。
她可能能够有
提升这个承托力
但是她就是会磨
然后她说
夏天出大汗的时候。
她都磨到那个受伤。
还有
有人就是那个
越野跑的背包
她说
就这个女孩
她说越野跑背包
她还磨脖子
然后有时候磨的
洗澡能撕下来
一条皮
我的天
我觉得就是
这个产品真的
就是我们都能
把人送上火星了
就是不能把运动
那一做好
最近不是买了一些。
羊毛的什么的
并没有改善的吗？
有改善
但是就是没有
我真的觉得
各方面都非常好的。
会不会有一种
我站在男性角度
会不会有一种可能是说。
可以解决这个问题。
但是解决起来
她的难度太大了
她很重要
我知道
但是她很重要
我觉得
就是我说
人都能上火星了
那一点不一样
上火星是为了说
人家的名字
这个地球上
一半的人就忍受
这件事情是吗？
这不重要吗？
不是忍受
是说
那这件事
这么多年了
还没有被开发出来。
因为女性
不是户外的
主力消费人群
她一直都被忽视
OK
哇 变得太激烈了。
但是真的
她真的挺难受的
你买了很多
很厉害的装备
她是个打底的东西。
但是我站在这个产品开发角度。
也不分同一些了吧？
就是
还没有找到解决方案。
没让你开发
Nike什么能开发一下。
就是大家好像暂时。
都没有找到解决方案。
没有认真做
不是没有认真解决方案。
绝对不是
这就是客户是吧？
对
客户客户
不管你怎么样
我觉得你没做好
肯定能把它做好
我觉得肯定能把它做好。
这个事就是
再加也有多大
你说那个我觉得特别好。
这个事呢？
不管是女性的这种。
应用内衣也好
或者是女性在户外。
上厕所这个事
多不方便
这所有东西
其实对女性讲真的。
是不是很友好的
就是因为我们
如果排队上山
特别有些雪山
你都去过那种地方。
你说这你怎么上厕所呀？
那不都崩溃了
而且你上厕所就很尴尬。
你不上厕所
你更难受
对吧？
所以这个包括
包括徒步也是一样。
你可能你比男生
更麻烦一点
对吧？
有时候男生上厕所。
有很多需求是
没有被满足的
但是呢？
实话实说
现在呢？
也没有什么特别好的办法。
你说雪山上
给你干一厕所吗？
也不太
我没让你解决厕所。
你先把内衣给我解决了。
就是一有的面料
比方说你能不能
某一款内衣
你就是把素杆
做的特别好
运动内衣
素杆是不是一个
基本的
基本的呀？
咱他能不能
就是我外面
T恤干了
他也差不多干了
别让我一直
湿乎的穿在身上
而且你知道
就是你到高海拔的地方。
他真的是凉啊？
很难受的
这个
你还没解决吗？
这个我觉得
我觉得随着大家
你觉得啥
你又不穿
不 我觉得这个
应该这么大需求
这么强于优
是的
但是我觉得
我就是前几天
刚看了一个
女生运动内衣的品测。
他就是
每半个小时去测一下。
最畅销的几款
都说这得是
素杆面料
他因为比方
他有些这个松紧的地方。
他后眼面料后眼
他就是干不了
但是他能干的
他又比方说
他特别薄
他衬托力做的不够。
就是我就是觉得
可能就是
有些东西他很难
我觉得肯定是
可以解决的
起码你比方说
你把你能不能
出一款技术杆
然后又不要那么薄。
就是会凸点
对吧？
有些觉得尴尬
不想穿这样
咱能不能就是
做到一个又素杆
又衬托力不错
不凸点的产品
去修我们得了
老师我们去得得了。
我们这款
咱就是这个中强度的。
咱也不用你越也跑穿。
咱就是这种
咱们能不能
出点这种产品
不要上来
就是跟我说
我这东西都是素杆。
然后我这款
就是这个是
高强度可穿的
然后你买回去
穿的时候发现
把胸绑在身上
特别不舒服
还干不了
叶老师
我有个不成熟的小建议。
会不会就是
这个问题
如果是很难两全了。
听起来就很难两全了。
说很像大
你要成多元强
就必须得厚
对吧？
说很像大
你要素杆
有可能把那场景
再细分一点
我瞎说
场景再细分一点
比如说你这种场景。
或者这种运动
你穿连就是大
那你就不能要
成多性
因为你必须也算是。
你才能保证你的素杆。
不是
我给你讲
我之前买过
路德曼那一款
那一特别好
我买了好
那一统一款
买了好多颜色来穿。
它就是
是个高强度的那一。
很宽
所以它不勒
不是那种细肩带
勒的你这个肩膀
特别痛
但它又是个高强度。
它的整个包裹性
各方面很好
它不难受
但他们家他们
你说它会凸点
你说凸点这个事
它难不难解决
其实一点都不难
你在那个位置
稍微做厚一点点
就可以了
你它老觉得
这可简单了
哪有那么简单
很简单
凸点很好解决
对对对
为什么一定要让女生。
让我贴个乳贴
再用你的这个
运动内衣
对
就是这个事
我觉得它就是很好解决。
但是设计师
没有多想
我觉得看到一个考虑趋势。
它一味的追求了
包裹肃肝
它可能就
没有考虑到说
可能有些人
它是有这个问题
你甚至比方说
你给我配两个胸背。
行不行
我自己可换
我不觉得这个事
真的那么难解决
有一个比较好的趋势。
是
我们上期也聊嘛？
就是因为现在
女性的参与
人数越来越多
然后我们的呼吁
以生也越来越大
所以这两年
有很多内衣在进行尝试。
包括我们前段时间。
咱俩讨论的那个羊毛内衣。
羊毛内衣
虽然别的没解决
至少它会
你在高海巴出汗之后。
没有那么冷了
对吧？
一个新材料的引入。
对对对
第二个就是
结构上的
我们马上
这周末要去
E-SPO
我们那一场就是
女
她的
忘了名字了
删掉
就是那款是关于
女性产品的开发
我的确看到
有一些品牌
是在做这方面的努力。
但是
我也承认就是
之前有很多没有开发到。
我觉得有能力问题。
但确实也有重视度问题。
就是偷懒
对就是
嗯
对
但是如果谁能
抓到这个商机的话。
我觉得一定会很有。
我在小龙山看到有一个牌。
有个牌子
我忘了什么牌子
就是特别小
然后他们家卖那个。
女士的四角内裤
卖得非常非常好
然后我就去说
是怎么？
谁要穿四角内裤
因为我
印象当中
男生会比较喜欢穿四角内裤。
后来我去看了一下。
他那个评论区
包括他那个
整个产品的页面
卖点什么的
我觉得他就是很好。
他就是
他就是很舒服
他不会卡
同时就是
他还能直接替代你。
安全裤
你不需要穿个内裤。
再穿一个安全裤
再穿一个裙子
或者什么的了
对
整个评论区的反馈。
都特别特别好
所以我觉得就是
未来是有这个希望的。
但我希望就是
大家都快点
不要很难吗？
就能能有那么难吗？
你做宇宙非常难吗？
现在是
我从商家的角度来想。
大家还是愿意做这种。
比如说
一个是
研发成本低一点的。
然后
或可能卖的多一点。
流通量
这种就很卷
你根本跑不出来
是跑不出来
但是呢？
就是他们
大家可能愿意做这个。
愿意做这个类型的东西。
我觉得这就是偷懒。
是偷懒
但是呢？
就是你
就活下去吗？
我想说活不下去
因为他太卷了
就说速干衣
你就说你速干衣
做的能比别人好到哪。
是
你印点不同的花
然后你做个
细分的使人区
你不如好好
做个愚人内衣
把它做好
我觉得这非常有市场。
米娅老师
给了一个非常好的idea。
感觉压力
到了我头上了
从小品牌
赶快行动起来
好的 收到
就有人家做
就你刚才老差
节目前不是也说
有个牌子
做那个女士的内裤。
做的特别好
一下子起来
现在做更多品类了吗？
你看你这么好
的产品兼区
有巨大的需求
没有被满足
是多好的市场
这才是活下去的方法。
我也感谢
谢老板站在
上家的角度
因为女士内衣
大多数人
有可能会穿的
吃马不合
所以它的退货率
是非常非常高的
其实一般品牌
像我们这样的小品牌。
其实是没有信心
和资金做这件事情的。
因为它的一旦
退货率特别高
我们根本承担不起。
但内裤这个品类
为什么这么好
它的退货率极低
然后它是高品发生的。
所以
那大品牌能做吧？
大品牌能不能
把这事做好啊？
是的
没难为你们
非得让你们做
它还能做
它也是要赚钱的
大品牌主的风险
巨高
然后研发成本有高。
投审主不一样
大品牌也不愿意做。
讲真
如果你是大品牌
我凭啥
我又不是就是主
我又不是圣人
我凭什么要做这个事。
我们今天
是为了角度讲事
正能参加角度讲事情。
我的意思就是说
它有它角度
它不一定愿意办这件事。
但是我们今天
说的不是说
哪些需求没被满足。
对
我是觉得这里面
是有个机会的
但是这个
比如说
我要是耐克
我可能把我整个
做女性运动
那一线的这个人
再调整一下
我就专门去做
就别说耐克
爱慕能不能好好做个。
它专门出了一个
做运动内衣的线
咱是不是
你就做这条线
你能不能把产品
做好点
呼吁收到
你就本身
就有这个基因
你就是做女生
内衣起家的
月下试试
月成我们了
领导任务
我还没有说
我的那个呢？
你说了一个
被女性被忽视的
对
然后我得说
一个男性
我就想知道
男性的忽视的
对吧？
然后我说
其实男性
你也是需要防晒的。
你会觉得
我不太需要防晒
对不对
看你的肤色
你也不太像
我在想
是需要不一样的
防晒产品吗？
我其实也需要防晒。
我并不怕黑
你怕晒伤
我怕晒伤
或者我怕晒
我晒皮肤
我怕这个
但是呢？
男的呢是这样
比如说
我有两个比较
喜欢的产品
一个是
我有一个唇膏
也是在
是在国外买的
它那个唇膏本身带这个。
防晒
因为我不用那个东西。
我一出业的话
晒我两天
我就有唇颜了
不然大家有没有这种。
是的
就那高海拔
晒的唇颜就是
又裂缚又什么反正。
就是很疼
我用那个呢？
它唇膏本身就带
一个人唇唇
另外它防晒功能
那个就特别好
就是这个
就是不是说
我不怕黑
我确实不怕黑
但我怕晒伤
包括脸一样
你像比如说
它推荐那个
那个棒棒
我没买过
防晒棒
我们有时候
一到了
说咱们有防晒双吧？
那手已经那样了
我不开玩笑
我就说
我都不好意思
可以抹墙了
对
我还得
忙手的急
我跟你说
我抹上去的一瞬间。
我其实是要忍一下的。
我忍不住
来吧？
你不是说
没有那么在乎
也在乎
那你们出发之前
会涂防晒吗？
我都是到了山上了。
防晒双带了吗？
忘了
咱们有带的
或者有那种
路上有
不是也有吗？
有互相之间就借一下。
所以出发之前
是想不起来
还是不愿意
包里可能都有
但是就忘带了
或者是没想起来
有的时候
不是不愿意
不是不愿意想
有这个需求
但我身边有很多男性。
防晒双的质地
所以他们不愿意涂。
有清爽的
清爽的
我现在其实我没懂的是。
谢老板说
这块是
你说男性容易忽视的。
一个产品
还是说
没有满足的需求
我是觉得什么呢？
比如说
我自己咱们
主义的时间长了
这种防晒的
涂防晒
我还能买得到
我还知道有这东西。
对吧？
有的人都不知道
涂防晒有防晒的
你看这信息差
我们所有女生
防晒高
纯高就是有防晒的功能。
很普及
我不知道
我是第一个
原来还有这种
因为我有纯严
如果这个不解决
我就会整个
后半成巨痛苦
因为它一直在裂
但我现在听起来
这个需求
其实是一个
消费者教育的问题。
而不是没有产品满足。
是吧？
那有没有针对
像男性那种
就不想太费事
我几个例子
比如那种喷雾
我就觉得挺好
有
但就是买就行了
有喷雾是吧？
有啊？
喷雾的效果好吗？
不好
就是这个问题
能不能比如说
男女的喷也不好
这个就是
因为它本身
你想它到空气当中。
再着到你脸上
它就是不均匀
对
它的沉默性就没有那个。
而且
非常强
你就
拎住呼吸
五秒钟
尤其讨厌有人在车上。
对
一个封闭空间
那个味道非常可怕。
可能是说
我们自己勤快点
有没有可能去像那种。
就是简单一点的
让我们没有那么大障碍的。
就给我们这种小白。
或者蠢用户
给我们简单
简化一下这个流程。
但确实
比如说我儿子
也不愿意用防晒霜。
他就觉得非常非常抵触。
他对那个质感
所以我在想
就是男性的需求里面。
可能也有一些非常。
细微的点
就是他们就不愿意。
接触那个
防晒霜的那个质地。
而且觉得麻烦
那就把那个防晒产品。
直接做到面霜里边。
但我觉得你那个防晒棒。
可能就是一个很好的形态。
他们比较简单
你拿直接拧出来
你就可以涂
跟唇膏一样
对
那他们说会堵色毛孔吗？
会堵色毛孔
不会
它其实就是
做成了膏状
它跟你手涂
那个防晒霜
是一个意思
一个意思
那这个棒
其实就是很好
而且它就是
真的你这样挨着
你涂一遍
它真的是能给你
防护得非常到位
你们涂完
或者拿那个特殊的光一照。
就能知道哪些地方。
它是
没涂
能涂到你反正
整个脸黑黑的
它是很那个啥
很防晒的
最近至少有两到
三个人问过我这个产品。
有些是听的节目
有些没听的节目
所以我觉得这个形态。
真的很值得开发一下。
它应该整个
即便在韩国
它也不是很
畅销的品类
为什么呢？
这么好的东西
我觉得我太适合了。
因为主流的防晒霜。
还是卖给
日常女性的客户嘛？
所以我们日常
比如说日常
我也不会用那个棒。
没有那么痛点
没那么明显
为什么日常不用棒呢？
它不会有防晒霜
那么贴合
或者符合我们的日常使用。
习惯
它附感上还是会
差一点
你想它是个高嘛？
它不像你一个
乳霜质感
上那个亲夫度更好。
它还是会让你
觉得有点闷
然后有些人
是因为他觉得
涂这个东西
容易那个
把妆给弄花了
对
就不愿意
补涂的时候
也不愿意用这个棒。
因为它这个面积
毕竟不是你的手指。
你可能可以
也可以这么弄一弄。
弄一弄
它整体就是很宽的一个。
但这个刚好是
男生不介意的点
对吧？
所以我就说
有些这个东西
本身不畅销
就是它
确实满足
是一个非常奇怪的人去。
我觉得男性特别好。
如果说我的话
未来比如说
一个唇膏
一个防晒的
然后你来
可以做完事
对
做男性户户的品牌。
感觉可以上这个行类了。
因为你那个我搜了。
我没搜到
我连那个
海鲜市场搜的都没有。
我那款退出中国了。
我自己后来
也买不到
我买的别的牌子
我只有后来
我就买什么？
自身糖都有
我就实在不行
我就买的别的牌子。
但是你那个牌子
我当时印象到
而且那个包装也很好看。
它很好用
它就是涂上去
它不腻
OK 这就是
我觉得被忽视的
也许不是被忽视
是个拥护教育的问题。
对
你回头发一下
在你账号
我跟你说
有一次
尼维亚
找我做一个视频
然后说
哥 这个你能弄去吧？
我说我这
看到眼门
眼门也不好弄
他说你弄
但是是男式的
后来中间
后来跟我说
哥 这个项目取消了。
我说被他取消了
他说
中国这男的
确实也是整不了
但他们家的纯高防晒。
冷知
是吧 冷知
他说他们家
那有什么精油啥的。
就是那一套男
男式的那么一套
洗脸的
精油的什么那一包的。
后来说
我说这个中国男性。
就是中国男性
确实在这方面
他说卖的不好
是吧？
他说这个也不推了。
说因为这个就不靠谱了。
这么个情况
投入传出比不小
对
我下面的问题
跟这个好像有点类似。
我们看还要不要打。
就是
如果让你开发一款。
新的户外产品
你最想解决什么问题。
你就想开发一个
女性内衣
对 但是我做不了。
不会 这太难了
这个开发有点
咱们可以下一个了。
这是一届
对
女性装备的机会
是不是也聊过了
就可以
直接到最后三个问题。
OK
好
那我们最后福利时间。
美人推荐
三件新手最值得
买的户外装备
最好带品牌
新手
哎 妈呀？
我这样
我先一个一个说
我说为什么要新手。
要买
从长期主义的角度来讲。
我特别推荐新手
他买一套
或者是一件
这种美丽多扬毛的。
这种打底
最好是捆绑的
我这个就是
但我这个
我就平时也穿
夏天也可以穿
然后在这种
质感也比较好
就是它是什么呢？
比如说我去外面也能穿。
我在日常也能穿的。
这种衣服
就是你新手你买它。
你也不吃亏
你正常你当个小T恤买。
你也是值了
就是打底裤
我觉得就无所谓了。
但是上一这个事
你有一顺手的事
你是建议大家
对这个材质
会有一个基本的感受。
是不是
对
一个是感受
另外一个是
我自从穿了这种
美丽多扬毛的
这种材质的东西之后。
我就会在平时
我就会喜欢上这种质感。
不然男的女的时候。
不一样
女的也喜欢
就那种懦懦的这种质感。
你会觉得很舒服
反正我比如说
女的会更喜欢
因为在空调房里
特别冷
我今天里边
我穿的都是
美丽多扬毛的一个背心。
我就会觉得那种质感。
让你觉得很舒服
就是区别于
我们原来的那种
就是前面那种
绵呀？
而且它还比较轻薄。
对
它不像以前那种绵。
因为原来愿意
那种体育现在不穿了。
不知道为啥
是这个
就是现在
可能对自己好了
我觉得就是
然后
还有我看看
还有再给我一点时间。
我应该
我准备了
蜜牙有推荐吗？
有笔记呢？
我看了
这个词
我等第五个楼
我放哪儿了
你找找
找找
你再给我点时间
一个是美诺扬毛的。
所以只推荐了一个。
推荐了一个美诺扬毛。
还有啥
我老板只推荐了一个。
对对对
我等会
稍等我一分钟
不着急吧？
不着急
小范好认真
还有笔记
我以为她只是
把你的提高打印出来了。
对
太认真了
怎么回事
第六大
这这这
这这
然后还有一个是
就是长期主义的吧？
长期主义的
一个是美诺扬毛
在这种上意打底
还有一个是
软褂裤是一个
特别好的裤子
哎这个特别好
因为其实很少人在。
刚开始买装备的时候。
会考虑到裤子
软褂裤
为啥我是觉得这个。
因为你平时也能穿。
就比如说这种软褂裤呢？
它是属于
就是你没有任何代价。
就等于我们买
要平时穿的裤子了。
你可以一直穿
户外也穿
你什么？
就说平时也可以穿。
而且它很适合在这个平时穿。
比如说我之前
那就是说一个吧？
就十尊一样的
十尊一样的那个软褂。
有点贵
大马
太好了
大马也是可备王
那个软褂的裤子
就有点贵
两千块钱
但是那个裤子
是我穿过的
我的版型太好
而且它还有一个好处。
它有个Shout版。
我的个儿不高
我穿的那个短版
得劲
真正好
真正好好
它这个是挺贴心的。
所以美诺扬毛
内搭
再加上软褂裤
这个是最长的
我们就是说
你买了之后
你可以把它穿过数次。
不像有些东西
你买完之后
可能你就吞机了
或者是用的概率不高。
这是我觉得是比较好的。
还有就是说
如果是说
安全感和体验更好的角度。
就是一个长期主义。
如果是安全感和体验更好的话。
那就是重装徒步鞋和扬毛。
就是两个
但重装徒步鞋和扬毛。
我之前都说过了
就不再展开说了
太好了
我想了两个
一个是
我觉得
我就挺推荐大家
买后卡的鞋子的
一个是你去外面徒步的时候。
可以穿
其实在城市里穿
因为它不稠
你搭一下
其实还挺长的
我觉得这个鞋子
挺值得入一下
然后包的话
其实我刚想到
柴她自己
最近出了一个包
因为她寄了一个给我。
我最近打球的时候。
在背
我觉得那个包就挺好的。
日常也能用
然后出差也能用
就那个产品的设计。
分层特别多
你放电脑
这个线 数据线
放什么化妆品
衣服
什么的
我觉得这种小包
就挺好的
大家可以
回头买一个
比方说就你家的
这个包
月下的
你阿姨推荐
我们的产品
我都有点不好意思了。
月下的
也长得很好看
反正我就是希望说。
这东西买回来
大家不用把它
把数值高隔
只有去户外的时候。
才能用
日常也用起来
一乌二用
性价比会更高
你们俩是同归了
对
然后刚才那个
新老板讲到
这个东西挺好的
就这个东西
而且我还挺建议大家。
就是买国产品牌的。
性价比很高
我现在自己试下来。
我在淘宝上
前段时间买了好多。
有些都没牌子
就他觉得他有牌子。
他就是个淘品牌
在我们心里
就属于没有牌子的。
他可能一个
颜貓T恤
也就
长袖T恤
可能也就200多300。
然后他那个
那都算贵的
微米做的非常非常新。
他能做到
比如说15.5
阿姨我先
就是女生穿起来
特别舒服
但你说15.5
你我到聪明阳
他不得买我800。
所以我就觉得
可能美丽奴这个产品。
大家可以多看看
国内品牌
对
就刚几老板讲的
日常穿也很实用
买了就回不去了
就是他
反正我现在
挺喜欢这种感觉的。
介乎于
绵合
他的那个负感
是介乎于绵合
敌人之间的
对
有点小小懦弱
然后他又不至于
那么的厚重
也不至于那么的滑。
就在中间
我就比较舒服
对
看来美丽奴羊毛
确实是一个大趋势。
我们在做的
百分之百的嘉宾
都买
对他都
我之前一刚买的时候。
我刚开始的时候
我不太喜欢这个材质。
就是因为买的是
那个海外的品牌
他那个比方18.5。
19.5
特别扎
我觉得你可能
就是男生可能
还好
对
本身汗毛
各方面多一点
皮肤可能没那么敏感。
女生穿就特别扎
所以我就一直对这个材质。
充满了敌意
后来才发现
其实你买
把那个微米
买得细一点的杀线。
就很舒服了
对
我们在节目之前
讨论我们那个月下羊毛。
挖也是
就当时做的会比
知名的那些品牌
更细一些
我觉得这是跟
质感就是不一样
人群不太一样
对
主要是
就是亚洲人
还是皮肤更嫩一点。
女性就属于
亚洲人里边的
可能皮肤比
更嫩一点
所以他这个
肤感皮肤
做的更细一点
男的
就是
男的就是说
一个是男的
他卖一个是
欧美人
欧美男的
对
还有一个是
欧美男的的脚
就是说
他欧美啥
做的那么粗
是因为
欧美的
男的本身就是
欧美男的
然后再加上
欧美男的脚
他还比
就是最低层级的
这种的
肤感
他们确实是
用更粗的杀线
但粗纤维的
杀线的好处
就是更耐磨一些
但是基本上
那个都是
为百公里的
那种徒步
我觉得
买
或者最容易交
智商税的装备
哎呀？
我先说
我觉得我就是
冲锋一夜
我真的不是建议大家。
一上来就买冲锋一夜。
而且通常也比较贵。
然后你有可能被
社交媒体上的
一些广告
什么诱导
你买一件不适
不适合你那个场景穿的。
就像刚才
谢老板说
因为用不上的
还所谓这种产品
对 我觉得
是一个
非常容易交
智商税的装备
谢老板
我想想
难住我了
难住我的点是
你后悔买过什么装备。
后悔买过什么装备。
是吧？
说对
最近找吧？
因为后悔的
应该有一些
但是我就有点
就是有点猛住了
最近是吧？
最近反正就是
买了一个套锅
套锅
买个套锅特后悔
后悔坏了
为啥呢？
就是那个套锅是
哎呀 那个套锅
我当时也是看
王一博他们用那个东西。
买完之后
那个套锅
不贵一套
大概是五六百块钱。
但是买完回来之后。
他那个锅
也是个北窝的牌子。
那个锅太老了
老的坏出啥呢？
一个是那个锅太重了。
我没有
我一会出去
把那锅本身很重
然后另外
他那是个极热锅
极热锅
炉子和极热片
他又套线不在一起。
我说
这你说给我
五六百块钱
我不是浪费了
我就觉得
就是你用起来
你就别入别的
更好用
然后你留在这
很难受
就是这么个
最近是觉得
这五六百块钱
高得有点贵
这个买之前
没太看一下重量
什么的
我看不到重量
因为是
这个国内
它也不是那种
淘宝天猫店
它就是那种
个人的店铺
听懂了
海淘虚谨慎
所以像谢老板这样的。
老江湖
也会受王一博
这样的影响吗？
你就是看到了
对吧？
他是一个机会
让你看到的这么个锅。
他本身
我这里边有一个
海国
还有好几个地儿
你知道我意思吗？
当时王一博用
我并不是觉得
他要有
我就必须有一个
我是觉得我要做一个视频。
去做一套
就是他同款装备的。
这样的视频
所以我觉得
这是个选题
其中一个
但是我觉得那总
我买
我总要有一个
就是说
他也值得买
我不可能说
我不喜欢的
我为了这个视频
硬凑一个屏
我觉得这个体验
还挺好的
但是我不知道
它这个底线
因为看不到这个东西。
没有人测评
这是很小众的东西。
极热片
它套线不太一起
哪有说极热锅
它不套线的防碰
一个小伙差
还不稳定
这是很尴尬
还有一问题是
炉子还让我买错了。
它那款炉子呢？
炉头呢？
有一款是非常好
它一拉
然后一折叠
炉头能翻过来
我觉得这个设计
它就更好能
收纳到这个锅里
结果呢？
我那炉子也买错了。
炉子还买成
那个不能折叠的
就是
彻底翻车
我就翻车到
我就很不够
我是这个钱也花了。
我是满意的
哪怕我是个炉子
炉子能折叠
可以很好的伤到
小锅里
我也认
那视频
这条还能拍吗？
能拍
已经拍了
但是就说
我会有点难受
纯为的视频
买了个素材
对
就不满意嘛？
那我就只能
为来不用
和一个很价格的
价钱
我就出了这本事
所以听起来
其实就是
刚开始
尤其是小白吧？
多去线下走走
多看看食物
挺有必要的
我就算是
我看那个
合理合理
时间也花了
经历也花了
对
最后一题
如果只给
只能给第一次
买户外装备的人
一句建议
会是什么？
但我在这儿
加一个前提
分别给男生和女生。
一句建议
一句建议是吧？
先说
我先说吧？
我想想
我想想这个
先说男的是吧？
对
男的就是
这个可以
适配给男的
跟你都可以
但是有时候
你只有使用了
这个装备之后
你才知道
你未来需要
什么样的装备和服装。
就是你如果
在你没有使用的
没有使用
就是比如说
你边用
边找
适合自己的
对
就是我觉得很重要的。
一定会
早期一定会
找到
买很多
你可能不适合
你边用
边知道
每个人的需求
自己的需求
女孩
就是
如果是女性的话
我是觉得
还是有一些
材料和数据
是要适当看
可以看一看的
说得很紧张
我到时候
视频播完之后
你们好多女性
互喷我
在她评论区里边说。
以后不要让小板再来。
我不想再听到
她的声音
不会
我们的用户都真的很好。
我给女生的建议
就是可能少看
社交媒体上的一些推荐。
多跟你周围真的玩。
户外的朋友去问了。
说这个东西好不好。
或者你给我推荐个什么？
就可能也有点像
谢老板刚才说的
你跟这种真实的
体验
体验过的人
才知道他好不好
不管是你自己体验过。
还是别人体验过的。
他可能比一看的
广告什么的更有用。
然后男生的话
我其实不是很确定。
但是结合刚才谢老板说的。
我在想可能
大家也可以多重视一下。
自己的感受
对吧？
没力度买得细一点。
他也更舒服了
就之类的
不一样
15.5真的是完全不一样。
那15.5我有一个15.5的。
他那个说实话
因为那种细度的
然后穿在身上
其实实话说不好看。
他会很贴
他不挺身
不知了
他就是一旦身材不好的话。
他就会变得非常的淡淡。
你只能打底穿
这都是专家的真心话。
对
但是身材好的人
那个衣服就是个无敌了。
所以就是说
但是那个衣服
服感太好了
我觉得那个衣服
每次出去
我就必须得戴那件。
感觉穿了跟没穿一样。
是吧？
对
15.5的
你说15.5我特别感受。
我就补一个14.5。
有那么细的吗？
有
我觉得这是营销化14.5。
不能相信他吧？
就算他夸张了也
他15.5
15.5
对15.5是真的没内能。
有14.5的
他可能
还有12.5的
你相信吗？
我觉得很多是营销化。
不是营销化
那对得一万多了
那就是12.5
那你说
我最后补充一个
给男性消费者的建议。
就是如果在户夫方面。
你们其实可以
勇敢的跟自己的伴侣。
或者身边的女性朋友聊一聊。
我发现这个信息差特别大。
其实很多都是我们的常识。
但是男生们
确实不知道
这可能真的各自
有各自的领域
是吧？
我认为那就是
我说你还有这种东西。
带防晒的纯高
其实是一个鸡草
刚刚很正经的
给我们俩安利了
带你去
对
真的吗？
谢谢你告诉我
我还说我说
我肯定你们俩
肯定不知道
其实我是在国外买的。
好吧？
再次感谢谢老板
和米娅来做客
然后也欢迎评论去。
大家有任何的问题。
也可以留言
如果你们想
更快的找到谢老板和米娅。
请前往小红书
谢老板的账号叫
谢老板的户外Vlog。
米娅的账号叫做
米娅
米娅胡
但是M-I-Y-A-H-O-O。
但是如果
你想看米娅的户外。
听到
就请去米娅再也
都没怎么更新
有压力了
对 大家也多关注一下。
月下的这个羊妈妈。
这个我觉得是非常棒的。
谢谢
是老板能穿吗？
对 能穿
我们的尺码
到35到43
对 都可以
好 那再次感谢各位。
如果大家还想听到。
什么他们俩聊的装备。
请在评论区留言给我。
我争取再邀请他们反查。
那我们跟大家说
拜拜
想要了解更多节目信息。
或许闻自己影像资料。
欢迎关注公众号月下。
三山五月的月
上下的下
小红书也有
我们的同名官方账号。
如果你也想和更多。
爱好者交流
欢迎加入我们的社群。
进群方式
添加小助理的微信。
月下Fox
Y-U-E-X-I-A-F-O-X。
拉尼入群
最后也欢迎你在全网。
关注我们的
女性户外品牌月下。
咨询小助理
可以直接获得
播客 听友
专属优惠券
让我们月下相和